welcome back everybody to the i am not
gm speechless championship grandmaster
robert hess alongside me today as per
usual my partner
grand mastermont hamilton amman we have
a great match-up in store between levy
rosman
and greg shahadi last time i was asking
you who you got
today's the day you got to make your
prediction
and put on the spot uh right from the
beginning well first of all hello robert
hello everybody welcome to what should
be
a an incredibly exciting match i mean
this is the number one seed greg jihadi
and i want to say fan favorite levy
rosman
um robert i i think that this match is
slated to be one of the closest but we
already saw levy participate
in what was the closest one so far
against eric rosen so
i mean who's going to win today i i
think that
i would probably say levy should be the
favorite
um based on the ratings and his recent
progression
however time trouble i'm going to cite
that right now is gonna be the number
one
uh factor number one uh thing to
consider when
uh you're cheering for levy well
speaking of time let's remind everybody
of the format of this event because
we start off with a time control of five
minute plus one second increment
75 minutes of that we then go on to the
three plus one 45 minutes in that time
control
and finally last but not least we get 25
minutes of
bullet chest at the time which will have
one minute plus one second increment of
course there can only be
one winner of not just this match but
the event as a whole
we know that there is roberto molina
awaiting
the victor of this match in the finals
who is it going to be greg shahadi
levy rosman greg being the top seed levy
being a mons choice
to move on based on his recent
progression his
rating gains and greg's going to say not
so fast
my friend we all always know that greg's
up for a good time he's up for some
friendly barbs
it's a rivalry no matter whom he's
facing and we do have the players on
camera
looks like greg he's he's getting his
pregame warm-up going on
look at him he's got some swag he's got
the cap on
what do you think amanda we're gonna see
four different outfits from greg today
or just this one
i think we might see the hat just slowly
rotate all the way around his head by
the end of the match
yeah that's probably a good guess oh
it's already off
and a bit of a different webcam uh there
on the right-hand side is
a little bit more conservative and
controlled
as we see uh maybe not just a pre-game
ritual but some actual
uh stretches some maybe it's gonna turn
into some jumping jacks uh
maybe he might get a whole workout in
before this match starts well we know
greg loves his crossfit so maybe he'll
do some exercises
with that in mind and it's going to be a
very tough match for the two of them
because as you've pointed out
and as we've stated levy has gained
quite a bit of rating in
recent weeks and greg is the number one
seed and he's the number one seed for a
reason
he historically has had the higher
ratings on chess.com
he is a long time speed chess player
he's well known he does a lot for
us chess in particular he's also quite
adept as his sister at poker
so it's going to be an interesting
matchup and well we're off
yeah this is a five minute portion just
getting underway
and we see a karakan already one thing
about greg
going to these matches is i never i
never
feel like he thinks he is the underdog
you know even if the ratings might
suggest
otherwise um greg is one of those
players that's so
traditionally consistent um he's got
that that type of style that
you know if he's ever going to lose a
match i feel like it's not going to be a
blowout either
no but i'm just kind of mesmerized by
levy's rating here i know he crossed
2800 i thought he went back below but
he's up to 28.20
in blitz and greg under 2700 so who's
the one seat here after all it feels
like
that should be levies and the c2 pawn
everybody don't go and scoop that pawn
off because that bishop could get in big
trouble
if it captures on c2 yeah this is um
a line actually queen a5 an interesting
variation definitely something that
levy has looked at this idea to support
the bishop
with the queen from a5 like normally you
don't really want to put your queen on
a5
how many times is the queen one of the
very first pieces that
we develop in chess we always teach
people the opposite bring your queen out
later
she might get harassed by the minor
pieces but we see queen a5 to support
the bishop
and then levy plays e6 once the bishop
has been developed
he's looking to get castle what do you
make of the
opening here robert a good good use of
time with the queen a5 queen back to d8
and now to c7
i feel like greg thinks he's playing
john bartholomew this looks like a
scandinavian and we know greg's trash
truck against hashtag team skandy
i think this looks great for white black
is extremely solid thanks as b7 c6
f7 e6 these two little pawn chains there
they
blockade the bishop on c4 no great
diagonals to work with
but white has way more space in this
position and easy plan
so i would certainly take greg's
position the early going
yeah the the thing about um these
positions when you're playing with white
is
you often feel early on like you have a
great position you're way ahead in
development i mean
white has moved every single piece
castle got both ropes in the middle
and his opponent's just going to catch
up that's how these like kind of closed
positions work is that
levy is going to have a lot of room to
improve his pieces over the next couple
of moves we see knight d7
we might see h6 at some point you know
rook e8 and and eventually
it looks like the move c5 although i
wouldn't do it uh right away
it's going to be one of the ideas to
break things open and levy trying to
trade off some pieces when you have less
space you want fewer pieces that's often
the case
and this movie h3 by greg maybe a bit
too slow i didn't really love that move
but bishop f4 he trades
pieces maybe he'll play c3 he does do
just that solidifying the center
i still like white's control over the
position however
black can now play rook to d8 because
there's no bishop on g5
yeah now that trading that bishop was um
very important but it was hard for
um greg to refuse the trade because
after bishop f4
now he can't go back to h4 the move h3
means the g3 square
is not under his control as much and
queen e3 often has the idea hey if you
take me i might consider taking with the
f pawn bring another pawn towards the
middle of the board
maybe think about e4 in the future and
have that full central control
that's a good call there and it's a very
solid position for both
greg has an extra almost 40 seconds at
this point you mentioned it partner
that the time management that could be
levy's downfall or perhaps he's just
getting himself settled in here it is
the first game of the match
and he'll quicken the pace as the match
goes on but after queen d6 knight h4 is
the move i want to see
because white sort of has done a whole
lot of nothing thus far solid position
but not spectacular
maybe play knight h4 and go after that
bishop he does just that
yeah and you've been calling out a lot
of greg's moves
in the game so far so just a small
small edge maybe for white with that
bishop
and this pawn structure doesn't look
like much but come in end game or
something like that
we could see those pawns actually
getting fixed with a move like h4
um so that's something long long term
but
no doubt is actually what these people
these players are thinking about
uh robert because the end game and
planning that far ahead is
something that players of this caliber
have to be doing at this point in the
game
it's an absolute necessity and your pawn
breaks the idea as you say
earlier with c5 you really want to get
that move in if you're black but then
there's a bishop a4
now pinning the knight on d7 to the rook
on the eighth the opening of the d-file
could be problematic for black in that
scenario so
i'm actually not quite sure how levy
should proceed and he plays b5 which is
quite thematic playing against the light
square bishop maybe knight to b6
in the near future i still prefer
white's position i love
this move h4 now you can even think of
going for an attack with bishop c2 pawn
h5
kind of breaking open the king side yeah
h4 is great and we see all of greg's
pawns they've
maybe without uh you know some of you
guys noticing but they've all
crept their way onto dark squares which
is exactly what you want to do when you
have a light squared bishop
start to put the pawns on dark squares
you'll notice that your opponent's bonds
are going to all be on light squares
they're all going to be targets for that
bishop on v3 as we see
the first sign of uh levy saying look
i'm trying to break things open
in the center with this move c5 uh
robert do we like this is it well timed
basically for levy
i think if he wasn't playing c5 now i
don't know when he would have been able
to do so and he's just trying to get
space for his
pieces one big issue is that pawn moves
for black
can actually help the white bishop for
example if you ever think about e5
think again and that's why he played
rook d4 because if you play e5 that
bishop on b3 stares at the f7 pawn so i
was just working my way through the
logic for a second and now we see rook
d4 played
because he's taking advantage of the
fact that black should not be pushing
pawns
off the light squares to open up that
bishop on b3
yeah no that's a great point rook d4 i
mean obviously the rooks can double up
next turn
that's something that levy has to watch
out for because that knight pin to the
rook is not acceptable and
if you play a move like knight f6 here
there's already going to be rook takes
d8 which would be
sort of a winning tactic i can just show
something like that rook takes d8 and
although you want to throw in the queen
takes queen first
you're going to be met with this check
on e8 and that would just be completely
winning as white
and it's going to pick up the queen on
e3 afterwards very good call and that's
why levy retreats the queen to e7 so he
trades off the c for the d-pawn
then brings his queen back to e7 i think
that
greg and he plays a4 trying to open up
the bishop but that
seems to allow some kind of knight c5
moves where the bishop on b3 is no
longer defended so
i i don't think that was a timely
decision by greg but speaking of time
he's up a full minute on the clock
yeah i think i think he sort of forgot
about knight c5
um it looks like a really strong
response actually
something as simple as doubling the
rooks there uh would have would have
probably been a little bit better um
even queen e2 just to hit the pawn but
a4 definitely mis-timed i think that
levy
with the move knight c5 has totally
equalized the game
a very good move and just finding the
difference
from the position the pawn a2 was
protecting the bishop now the bishop not
left
protected and that's why knight c5 you
can then take this pawn a4 but that's
not the end of the story right
if you go ahead and try to take on a4
when when or if white recaptures there
safely
that a7 pawn can be a weakness to put
pressure on but black should be doing
okay here
yeah i i think um okay he goes for the
rook trade first he had a choice does he
want to
take on a4 um the reason i think he
decided ultimately to take the rook
first he didn't want the rook to end up
on a4
with the queen ganging up on the a7 pawn
instead
more pieces off the board it's easier to
defend your weaknesses
and now here's a big moment and this
allows queen to b4 which can
say white's keeping that bishop because
that knight is pinned on c5 i don't
think it's that big of a deal
from an evaluation point of view but it
just changes the trajectory of the game
if white is able to keep the minor piece
dynamic
that you currently see on the board yeah
rook d8
queen before black would have to maybe
king f8 or maybe queen c7
um and it looks like there is going to
be a knight d3 move
uh if he wants to make sure to trade
bishop for
um yeah bishop for night so i think
queen c7
with knight d3 coming after bishop c2 if
he wants to say look get these pieces
off the board
you know start this this first game off
properly in what
looks like it should be uh headed
towards the draw right now yeah it looks
pretty level i
still see the extra time for white i
think that black's pawn
on a7 is quite a vulnerable pawn
relatively speaking
but it still is level i like the way
that levy's been speeding up because
he's playing much more quickly
after the opening stage and right now
the time is evening up the position
seems to be evening up as well i think
he has very good chances in this game to
just neutralize anything that white
thinks that he's going for
100 uh queen back to a3 guards the b2
pawn
and uh at this point queen a5 looks like
a move i would
uh consider i wonder how he's planning
to meet queen a5 actually
i guess you have to by default play rook
d4 which looks really strange but saying
hey please do take my bishop have fun
with that one
because then the rook takes on a4 and
then a7 falls so
uh that i think rook d4 is the only
choice you can move the bishop away but
i don't like
ruining my own pawn structure so of
course craig brings the rook up a second
time in this game
yeah he's used that d4 square before um
there is maybe a rook to b4 move that
um could also be played next bishop can
can move but really what you don't want
to do is white you don't want to move
your bishop and maybe have to treat
queens on a3
it's going to disconnect the pawns all
of a sudden the c pawn is sort of going
to be isolated weak
and the black king reaches the center a
little bit quicker than white's king
looks like it's very comfortable on e7
so as soon as those queens trade look
for black to play king f8 king e7 but
how important is the time gonna be in
this end game i think it affected his
decision
the play knight takes a4 yeah now he's
like queen e5 or something get that
queen in with a bunch of checks because
he's 10 seconds
just give up the a7 pawn you can't
defend it's under attack two times
so there he goes queen d8 and now if
greg takes on a7 there will be queen d1
check and probably
just a perpetual because the king on g1
doesn't have true shelter
yeah if you ever move the king away from
the f2 pawn it looks like there's always
going to be
you know a queen d2 move just to hit the
f2 pawn and the b2 pawn so
um i hear you i think it is going to be
king g2 king g1 back and forth
i think it's a necessity for both sides
of this point and let me think he's
3.4 seconds left he's scaring me on the
clock here but he is just going to bring
his queen back
d1 d5 on that yoyo string nothing to
really think about
no i think he just had to make the
decision like hey
do i actually have more here maybe he
was thinking about rook d8
i'm trying to get the rook involved as
well but with 3.3 seconds you know what
i think
in game one we don't need to be taking
those type of risks save that one for
you know match point and greg could lose
the game if he was king h2 he has two
legal moves and khu
loses i believe after queen f3 and rook
d as you were saying so he is agreeing
for the draw at this point
and levy did not pre-move that which is
very smart in the event
that greg was trying to trick him and
play king h2 so good mouse skills
good blitz and bullet uh acumen and
clicking age two
what is he doing he's gonna lose the
game he just walked into a loss
rook d.a like rook dude it's over and
then rookie one for gage with me
and you know what levy levy like baited
him in basically because
it's it's levy having such little time
and that's a game over rook d2 it's levy
having no time robert that baited him
and is saying look
i i'm up a minute in this game i can
flag this guy
and he walks right into checkmate in
three basically
that is i would say quite inexcusable
for a player
as experienced as greg shahadi there was
no need to do that
it was game one and it's still only one
game done with
but that can change the entire nature of
the match where now you're playing catch
up
after a game you feel unsettled by your
decision making
so greg needs to right the ship here
that doesn't mean he has to win this
game of course even if he loses he still
has
good opportunities in the match but
amman that just feels off
yeah it definitely does um it's as you
mentioned it's not something we're used
to
player of his caliber missing but it's
also not something that's really in his
style like
i've known greg to be usually very okay
with taking a draw here and there
just moving on to the next game not
really trying to over push
um in situations like that but you know
this is an important match the winner
goes to the finals in this tournament
robert
and i think he felt like look game one
the the clock is a piece that's what
that's what we say in blitz chess and
if you're gonna be down a minute on the
clock greg is just thinking to himself
as a
any good chess player would look i got
to punish that somehow
uh i want more than a draw here and he
simply over pressed he asked for too
much
and with three seconds left on the clock
uh levy
very impressively just finds all the
moves and easily uh comes with that win
and people always ask when do i pre-move
how do i prove levi did a great job of
not
pre-moving there because hadn't even
pre-moving he actually would have lost
that game so greg tried to be tricky it
failed him
in this game game two we saw in the
opening
while we were speaking and not really
paying attention so much but i'm looking
at the notation
greg early on with bishop c5 and then
his next one was bishop from c5 back to
e7
so that evidence is to me that he's been
preparing
he is looking at levy's openings knows
that he would go for this vienna type of
position and so he was fully able to
retreat the bishop without thinking
twice about it and speaking of time
advantages
once again greg is up a minute on the
clock
yeah and i i mentioned at the beginning
um because i think that
that's just always something that's
going to be in levees matches
uh it's not something you can tell them
like hey man just play a little faster
you know
let's just forget let's just not have
all that time trouble because that's
just the way he plays you know live by
the sword die by the sword
he he got into time pressure but we saw
in game one already in this match robert
he's able to play well under time
pressure
and find enough accurate moves to
deliver a checkmate on the spot so
um like i said it's it's something that
might annoy you as a levy fan like dude
just play a little bit faster but
i mean it's how he gets his wins as well
his position looks great
right now with the pressure against the
black king after
i don't even know how to take on d5
knight takes bishop takes both look
really good i like bishop takes more
even immediate threat with knight takes
g6
and the f7 pawn is pinned uh king to g7
looks like you're
barely holding on there could be some
kind of queen g4 or
bishop takes f7 to follow you to be
super careful in a position like this
but i do believe that greg has to do
something like a king
g or h7 just to not lose a pawn on the
spot
yeah definitely um knight e7
is like maybe it may be a move but as
you can
tell by my intonation there robert
that's not a move i'm super happy to
play uh knight d7 just going backwards
and
even if uh levy just has to play you
know bishop back to b3
it united on e7 is doesn't really have a
bright future ahead
you know i like your move though 97 at
least challenges white setup for the
time being because we can't just allow
the bishop to sit in the on d5 or knight
on f4
it feels uncomfortable but greg does
move out of the pin
but that leaves the f7 pawn a bit
vulnerable right there's only one
defender currently one attacker
when the knight moves out the way the
rook is gonna team up maybe there's a
queen b3
to keep an eye on so i just feel like
greg's position is
quite vulnerable right now lots of loose
things happening on the king's side
definitely uh levy's about to get one of
the best
structures against the bishop pawn on b2
pawn on c3 and pawn on d4
is going to be perfect against both of
black's minor pieces so
full control of the center uh basically
every minor piece in levy's position is
a little bit better than the counterpart
in greg's position and levy seems to
have the fundamental knowledge of this
position to
just play very simple chess frankly he
gave his dark sport bishop
then brought his knight into the center
he has a bishop on a great diagonal he
put
broke free the f-file by playing f4 and
now queen g4 play watch out for bishop
takes f7 that's clearly the threat
so i think greg has to play a move like
knight to e5 or your knight e7 move
from earlier he plays the more active
try but that could also mean that the
knight gets kicked
in the next few moves yeah the this pawn
d4 is gonna happen one thing to watch
out for
uh for greg in terms of counter play is
after the move d4 happens
you might really quickly look to play
moves like queen b6 c5
and put a lot of pressure on that pawn
so it's not like levy just gets the
center and gets to keep it the whole
game as soon as he takes it
greg is going to be looking for those
attacks from the flank
um c5 and he is going to be putting some
pressure on the center
and he goes bishop h force just trying
to kick away
white's forces levy just puts his queen
on h3 says what's next i'm i'm going to
play d4 whether you like it or not
and i don't even know what to do for
black queen e7
feels like a move that you play just to
keep f7 defended for and now
but there could still be some tactics
flying in the near future so i think
that greg's in a tough spot he should
spend
quite a bit of time because he is up on
the clock and
amman what about b5 just to get the c4
square potentially i say it
right with a question mark as i make the
statement
i feel like you and i have both
suggested moves for for greg
with question marks at the end it's a
tough position to play that's what that
means um
it really is the the opposite bishops we
always say in chess that
you know sure those might present
drawing chances in an end game but in a
middle game
where there's queens on the board and
tactics flying everywhere they actually
do help the side that is attacking and
in this case
if there's one side attacking one side a
little more aggressive than the other
it's going to be levy in his position
right there you can see
based on the queen's position that's
exactly what it's indicating so that
bishop from a2
doing a lot of work with tactics on the
f7 square g6
even just bringing the rook over rookie
one g3 to support the knight a lot of
just solid options for levy but no
knockout blows that i can see well i
think bishop takes f7 i'm only
using the hint of the eval bar as i
looked in my periphery bishop takes f7
would justify a plus two and a half or
whatever that says
so i think that there's bishop f7 with
96 to follow
because of the pin on the h file taxes
galore we showed after the game but i
think that was a missed opportunity from
levy
yeah 96 and i mean that's that's what
it feels like to get that little nudge
from the eval bar you know there's a
tactic whereas
you're in levy's position you don't have
that uh you don't have that knowledge
it's
it's uh hard to find those tactics in
the game but i agree that that did look
very promising
and it was because of that nudge as you
pointed out because it looks like a
position that's very promising still
for white but we see that the evaluation
bar is closer to the center
which means that white missed some
opportunity and it was very hard to spot
because you had to see the line all the
way through you don't just sacrifice a
bishop for a pawn
and hope that it works out no you really
have to calculate and levy doesn't have
all that much time left it was a
difficult tactic to spot
so we of course understand his decision
making and right now greg
is countering ahmad all of a sudden he
won h5 will he play h4 and get a
kingside initiative of his own that's uh
h4 might be good
not even for the initiative on the
kingstep but maybe even just to prevent
h4 by white
kind of gains a little bit more space in
an otherwise cramped position
we see both players in the last couple
moves um
they've ended up putting their kings on
g7 and g2 which is the opposite color of
the
of the opponent's bishop so it's a nice
safe square for the king bishop h6 drops
back
um i think this might just be
pre-emptive expecting h4
yeah it's what are you gonna do about it
levy and right now levy down to a minute
three seconds he plays e5
which means that greg has to make an
important decision does he play d5
looking to close he does but does that
allow some kind of e6
not yet the work on the fate stares
through the f file at the queen on f3
so e6 would be the move you want to play
but you need to time it well
yeah and he owes bishop b1 uh because
levi is saying look i'm not interested
in having the bishop on a2
going c4 or trying to open that diagonal
uh i'm done with that diagonal it's on
to a new one after the move e5
b1 to h7 just opens up for that bishop
we might see moves like
knight to f4 or i like even the slower
move like rook f2 rook e2
just intending to always double the
ropes one way or the other
and he plays knight f4 and bishop takes
you could probably take with either
piece g takes looks interesting because
you want to
use that pawns of battering ram till f5
that g3 pawn
going up the board trying to open up the
black king and that's why greg is
thinking here he does not want to take
that knight but he may feel like he has
to
because of a sacrifice an h5 or a pawn
e6 type of move or a mon
it looks like combining your ideas with
rookie two now you can double
depending on what takes place next on
the f file most likely or the e file if
something were to open up if black said
uh you know made some kind of move that
like f6 and you can't do it now but if
that were the case
then you may want to use the e file
instead yeah no it's just a flexible
move it also guards that pawn on b2 um
this e3 square just something to keep an
eye on in case the knight moves i'm
looking at stuff like knight takes h5
and
i'm sure levy is as well very tempting
bishop
takes f4 played i instinctively like g
takes f4
myself here g takes a four using that
pawn
thrusting it forward to open up the
black king but after g takes it forth it
could be
f5 for black like a desperation please
let's keep the position closed
and if you don't take on passant which
you are legally allowed to do
then maybe i do have some kind of
defensive set up and greg goes for f5
and levy is 28 seconds now
to figure out does he take on busan or
does this actually help black
yeah i would not take that um i would
just move the king probably to h1
um just bring the rooks to the g file
and there's going to be
some combo of like bishop f5 rook takes
g6 and queen h5
this game must end tactically because
that knight on c4
robert it cannot participate in the
defense at all
yeah that's the biggest difference at
that night we're on e7 you may think
that black could survive this
but look at rook g5 taking on h5 is an
immediate threat
taking out f5 as a threat as well this
might just be over with actually
i i just don't see how the pieces can
defend uh
white has one two three four major
attacking pieces
the rook on e8 and the knight on c4 are
not defending at
all so it's just you know you just
outnumbered i feel and that's a great
move
keeping f5 keeping everything defended
and i don't see a knockout you have 10
seconds for levy you got to move but
then you get
a kind of impatience and rook takes h5 i
got to do something no he plays rook to
g2 look at that move that is calm
yep it's covering d2 uh and i don't i
don't like this king h6 it's covering d2
and it's covering the pawn on b2 there
and yeah greg brings his king up it
looks like you're only walking into
harm's way he's
okay queen h4 is what i want to play but
i still don't see the checkmate
yeah it's it's true there's a
doesn't appear like there's a checkmate
on the spot at all
93 look at this knight coming to the
rescue yeah g4 and there's
knight f2 check if you're not careful
and wait the c5 opening doesn't amount
to anything just yet
two seconds you gotta move greg okay ace
they both need to move
quicker than they think right and
they're playing a bullet scramble
neither king is safe and whoa that's a
big decision there it might just be
winning queen and tries to make
made in one that's made in one woo well
done by levy there
wow yeah that was really well done and
it's so weird at the end it's like the
uh i know i'll just flip back to that
game because i feel like
no one was able to really uh take in
exactly what just happened there at the
end robert but
uh look at the hero bishop by the way
covering
c2 covering e2 covering e4 it's like the
only reason
that levy's alive in this game and he's
i think he's winning because of it
yeah that was really nicely done he did
not get impatient he could have
sacrificed his rook
earlier it did not work out it seems an
earlier time so he waited
he found the opportune moment he seizes
on it and he wins a second game in a row
and now greg's definitely regretting his
decision from game one
because he did not need to lose that
game when he had to draw by repetition
just at his fingertips 100 100
this is starting to slip away in the
early stages
nothing to be too concerned about in my
opinion but
uh something to uh at least you have to
consider
how greg might be feeling these two
early losses
i don't think he's ever started a match
this way robert
no and i think what greg needs to do is
start spending two minutes in the
opening
to get levy out of his comfort zone levy
is the one who's always down on the
clock so maybe greg needs to say
hey i'll have what he's having and do
that but right now he's trying to break
open the center
this reminds me of some games we saw
between eric rosen and levy
in the quarterfinal matchup and there's
pressure on that d5 pawn
which is uncomfortable for black
especially because you haven't castle so
there could be
some opening of squares and diagonals
that you have to look out for
yeah and i i thought that at least when
we watched these games
with eric rosen we eventually
sort of concluded that the knight on e4
the plan involving knight e4 supporting
it with f5 was the good plan so
doubtlessly levy spent some time looking
at this
for the last match and for this match
knowing that greg
would you know could easily go right
back into this this is again
transposition from the carol khan so an
opening that these guys both
probably knew was going to be on the
table for this match that's right and
i'm looking at this position i once
again
like with the position greg has here but
levy has studied this very deeply so
uh you know if you're sitting here and
looking yeah it looks like there's
better development for white your castle
there's pressure on d5
but levy has played this time and time
again clearly he knows what he's doing
although i must say i'm on i really do
like white's position
yeah i mean he must know what he's doing
but
he's down two minutes on the clock
robert you know so maybe that's just
levy things
uh or he's trying to remember a line but
but what i'm looking at here is
something i'd have to agree with you on
uh
pawn on c4 attacking in the center
basically as soon as white
gets a rook to c1 you start to feel like
the position just just flows and this a5
a4 plan
in order to basically quote unquote
defend
the d5 square if that's quite something
and it's a bit slow because the king's
in center so you can take and then take
on e6
because there's a queen hanging on d7
with check so d takes e6
you've already taken two pawns and black
will get one of them back but it feels
like white
must have the upper hand in the ensuing
queenless middle game
yeah has to be i would say but in this
position i mean
i feel like a5 as you mentioned robert
is not the type of move that you just
sit at a chess board
and think of like it that's definitely
in
some file that he studied somewhere is
it going to be exactly here
i'm not sure but it's definitely
something that is going to lead to a
position like right now
where i feel like he's seen something
like this before and he knows maybe he's
not just dead lost
at least there's some compensation as
greg has to play a3 due to the pin from
the aaa rook black is very active
yeah there's actually quite a lot of
compensation because the extra pawn is
this isolated pawn on d4
not doing that much yet so black has the
activity that white needs to be careful
about
but this pawn on b3 that pawn can be
attacked with a rook d1 rook d3 maneuver
at some moment
i i think that for now black can claim
an okay position
thanks to the activity but once it's
warded off then
greg's advantage will really show itself
yep 100 um that pawn is kind of
everything in the position
as you mentioned without that pawn on b3
and white's pieces are a lot more free
to move around the knight on e3 also
doing work here because if that black
brook is able to get down
and sort of entrench itself on c2 it's
all about the light squares in my
opinion
in this game if you know we see king e6
knight d5
trades could even be good here for levy
we can see something as crazy as like
king e6 king
captures d5 and it's actually totally
safe on d5 and very very
uh good in the end game yeah that king
would be an amazing block hater against
that isolated queen pawn there
and greg is trying to figure out the
best way forward he can play rook d1
does he have time to go for
that rook lift to d3 and take on b3 it
does look like it's very time consuming
and white's position is awkward around
the board here but i don't
really know what black's immediate plan
is as you point out the 93's such a
strong piece
taking away the c2 square so will black
commit to move like pawn f4 that puts
the pawn on a square
that's quite vulnerable so i'm not sure
that you'd want to do that allows the
knight to get to g4
and then to e5 if you play f4 so what's
black's response right now
yeah rookie one uh has two purposes
uh what i can see number one as what you
mentioned
simply rook d1 rook d3 rook takes b3 the
other one
and it sort of ties in with maybe the
move f4
is the knight can come back to f1 which
is now available and then hop to d2
challenging the knight on e4 but also
making sure that if you capture on d2
well i've got this knight on f3
it can also capture on d2 and i i don't
see a way to defend that b3 pawn
that's a really good point so maybe you
have to play some kind of rook lift for
black to defend the pawn but you don't
want to
sit a rook just defending that pawn on
b3 you need to be active you're down a
pawn
so you're offsetting the material cost
with your activity and so you do not
want to play some kind of rook c6 to b6
that feels
a bit off here so let's see what else
can be done for
black can you try b5 b4 and just rush
that pawn through
it seems like rook d3 takes b3 would be
the answer to that
yeah b5 b3 comes to mind or b5
b4 rather comes to mind also trying to
use the b4
square in general so it could be a piece
as well like one of the only things that
that levy has in the position um that
greg can't really deal with
too nicely at the moment is this pin
from the 88 rook so we could see
either this knight or this bishop plant
itself on the b4 square
for example bishop b4 could be one way
to try to deal with knight f1 knight t2
but
rook a6 maybe he's saying look if i have
to plant a rook
on the b6 square you know i'd rather use
the one from the a file so
at least i'm still in that open file
there with rook c8 and greg
quickly plays rook d3 i you know we're
anticipating rook b6 to defend the pawn
he can play bishop to d2 he can finally
develop that piece
it may not be going anywhere after that
but at least the rook on a1 is free to
move around the first rank
and then black still needs to come with
a plan greg has an extra
minute and 15. he said just double
levy's time
and he has the extra pawn here but
converting this will not be
an easy task no it's as soon as you move
that knight on e3 for like a knight f1
plan
you also give up a lot of light squares
in the middle knight d2 played
um i think i don't think there's any
tactics that he's
um considering just taking it here
because knight p3 is
very hard to stop it's funny i was like
oh i'd rather you take me on e4 and then
i forgot the b3 pawn was under attack a
second time by that move so
yeah you sort of had to take on d2 now
the bishop
would like to come to the c3 square
where it blocks the c5 protects b2 and
this knight d5 for black blockading
the isolated queen pawn this is what
we've learned a long long time ago from
the likes of mimsovich and kappa
blanca's games
it's a very good square to blockade in
but you can't get your king to blockade
it like you said earlier mon
you would love to play king e6 but
rookie one check will kick the king away
king c6 walks into rook c1 ideas that's
no good either
so unfortunately for black you kind of
have to back down from the square
yeah um if you try to occupy the square
now you simply run
into d5 as well so king e6 you wouldn't
want to check
with rookie one king d5 would happen and
that king
surprisingly in the center of the board
is actually very very strong so instead
king six would be met by d5 we see those
milliseconds start to appear and with
two minutes down if that becomes a
regular thing
in this match i feel like greg is slowly
gonna get back into this uh i just feel
like
although levy is talented uh you know in
time scrambles
you can't do that to yourself every game
no you certainly cannot and here after
rook b5 trying to bring that rook on the
fifth rank
i was thinking about a4 a5 and trying to
use the a file
uh to open that up with the pawn and
then use the rook there but there's that
rook
blockading on d5 and now b5 but b4
can't really be played too easily i'm on
what i'm wondering is can i get to that
b3 pawn i don't want to move my bishop
because your rook lands on c2
but at what point can i just say uh to
heck with the c2 square
i'm winning your bomb yeah i think it
could be sometime
pretty soon uh white has to make a
decision because if you bring the king
too far towards the queen side there's
also the move rook g5 which is really
annoying hitting that
g2 pawn it's not easy to defend so
instead
he's saying look my queen side is where
i have the extra pawn here if you're
greg
but it's all locked up and now i'm just
gonna use my rook and go harass all your
pawns well what he's really gonna use is
extra time two seconds left
for levy here and he's barely holding on
to the g7 i think h4
followed by h5 then you go rook back to
g5 i'm just trying to win your
pawn on g7 it feels like there must be a
way at this point
i'm not quite seeing it though uh h4
rook g6
d5 um might also hit the pawn pretty
nicely
yeah that looks good d5 check opens up
the bishop then you can bring your rook
back over to g8 if you need to
or to a7 depending on where the black
king goes but 2.2 seconds left
not going to cut it when it's a very
complicated position and
reg is up a pawn yeah i think uh d5 here
like
rook takes rook a6 it's already you know
if you see a trick like that and your
phone has two seconds
he almost just plays the move
immediately um it's really hard to
process tactics like that uh very
quickly so
yeah he's gonna have to move the king
and he plays pick c5 i think
isn't rook a6 just very good here there
could be some kind of like rook takes c3
idea but it doesn't work but you know
what i'm saying like the free open
free the beep on to call queen but it's
not in time there's all
every capture happens with check right
yeah now that uh
that looked like it was uh going to be
decisive so uh we've seen
basically we've seen exactly what i
predicted was going to be the case we've
seen a lot of time pressure
and we've seen that time pressure pay
off for both sides because
it's actually been the time pressure in
uh early on in game one
which caused uh greg to go a little bit
crazy and think that he could win that
game
levy stayed right with it converted and
punished him for for
that and then well we see the time
pressure here costing
levy a game um already so now it's two
to one and
you know greg is crawling back in the
match i would say by the chest
it's been completely even and it's a
split second decision that has made the
deficit what it is
two to one in levy's favor that first
game greg could have taken the draw he
decided to play on
levy very smartly had his bullet skills
his mouse speed
he was there for he was able to convert
that game after greg said no draw for
you
he said well why thank you and after
this we have a 2-1 lead for levi rosman
we'll be back shortly for more from the
i'm not gm speechless championship
brought to you by chess.com
so far it's a two-to-one lead for levy
rosman over greg shahadi
amman levy was your pick your prediction
before the match
still feeling good about that one and
for the first three games
well uh i guess the answer has to be yes
i mean obviously early lead
is uh good stuff especially because you
know levy is
uh in these blitz matches uh sometimes
the time pressure that he gets into
becomes more apparent
there's simply more time on the clock so
you'll get these crazy time
disadvantages like
one minutes two minutes whereas when the
bullet starts
levy somehow just grounds himself and he
usually plays a lot faster so
i feel like if the shaky portions uh you
know are
usually in the blitz then things are
sort of looking better from here
and the players have talked about this
where they're not used to playing this
five minute time control it's like seems
like you've all the time in the world
because they're used to playing three
minute or bullet chest
and you get into these comfort zones
where you just mismanage your clock
because you believe you have more time
you just get this feeling but right now
we're in game four levy with the white
pieces goes for e4 again and greg
says no vienna for you let's play the
sicilian so greg did not like
what he achieved in game two we didn't
like it either
so i think it's a smart decision to
switch it up i don't blame him and a
veteran
like greg in these match formats he's
played so many of them and he's so good
at them
he knows that one of the most important
skills to have
as a competitor and a player in these
type of events is to be
able to adapt on the fly you can't be
the guy who only has one opening
and it you know you get a bad position
and what are you gonna do play the same
opening again
and just hope to improve it well your
opponent's probably done some research
as well it doesn't just work like that
so the fact that he's able to switch
up his openings after one bad game he
might even go back
uh you know after he gets another break
and maybe more time to look
he might go back to to uh those vienna
positions but
um i think he's happy to switch it up
and he's showing that versatility
already
and it can be risky to do things like
this against certain opponents but
against levy
and the way levy spends his time i think
it could pay off for him we'll see
right now the queen's on c5 you
typically don't like your queen being
out in the open
like this because knight d5 and there's
threats to get to the c7 square forking
the king on the e8 and the rook and a8
i'm just not sure if knight d5 works at
this moment the b2 pawn is hanging
maybe you just move your knight out to
a6 at some point i don't know the
intricacies of this line
yeah this this line is um obviously greg
is taking a little bit of a hit here in
terms of and
there's that knight d5 move he's taking
a bit of a hit in terms of how accurate
the opening is it's not top tier
but he's doing so on purpose he he wants
to get an offbeat position
um against levi he wants to change it up
from last time so
he's kind of taking a hit here on the
evaluation as you can see the evaluation
bar creeping up
early on to have an advantage like 1.5
uh robert is
already looking great for levy i think
he can choose to maybe use a lot of time
here
and try to punch home a very significant
advantage or you can just develop
just get the pieces out and try to get
castle i can see the
eva bar off the side of the screen here
i think it's misleading because it's
probably
one way where you actually have an
advantage that large where most moves
was normal looking moves
black is able to develop and get rid of
that edge so bishop b5
the point being the c7 square would be a
fork if you take that bishop but after
bishop b5 is queen b7
and then it's like well okay i have all
my pieces on these really cool looking
squares
where to next and how do i actually sort
of win material
or do something concrete rather than
just good looking moves
yeah and bishop b5 queen b7 it's this
hilarious position where the only two
things greg has accomplished is
fianchettoing his
bishop on g7 and fianchettoing his queen
on b7
not not good we don't advise that for
all of our viewers out there
but right now speaking of fianchetto
greg can just play bishop b7 because the
queen will have the c8 square
to retreat to he can also think about
bishop a6 you
want to see that if you are levi because
you haven't developed your light square
bishop yet
so perhaps you can just trade all at
once or even consider a move like c4
that looks interesting to avoid the
trade and claim more space
i like to look at both of them but i
would say bishop takes asics and just
castling is particularly appealing
um do so with with tempo the one thing
is
you will have to drop that bishop back
and levy's already going for something
a little bit more complicated knight d4
and i don't think this game is going to
be
so easy greg has one main issue to deal
with which is
the e7 pawn he can't really play knight
f6 to get castle
because the e7 pawn has been targeted
the entire game that's right and he
is going to try and play knight to c6 at
some point soon once he trades the light
score bishops off
if you take on a6 then the knight takes
on a6 which hits the bishop on b4
so greg is sort of developing with a
tempo here and there
to try to neutralize white's lead in
development and because that's knights
on d5 and d4 things are hanging the e4
pawn behind the knight on d5
the knight on d4 is a bit loose with
that bishop one g7 staring there
so he plays bishop b5
okay it's kind of funny i was actually
going to suggest this move but
i thought nah this is just too weird
almost looks like a mouse slip or
something
or bishop takes a6 but i mean the the
idea is there basically he
doesn't want to help uh greg develop
with knight takes a6 he says look i'm i
need to castle so i got to move this
bishop how about i go to b5
you can't or you don't want to take me
bringing the knight there with the c7
fork that you mentioned earlier
and if you remove the defender of b5 the
bishop takes d4
suddenly there's queen takes d4 and the
rook on h8
is uh kind of wishing you had some
protection i think we should show this
one the analysis board because another
problem is after bishop takes b5
knight takes b5 knight a6 it looks like
you covered the c7 square
then there's bishop takes e7 because
that knight on b5
also wants to go the d6 square which is
check forking the king and the queen and
it would have been checkmate if you
didn't take that bishop
yep no there's there's a lot of tactics
here and
you know um the other one being bishop
takes d4 queen d4
hitting the the rook there so it's not a
lot of time to play bishop takes b5 so
yeah this
there should be five looks like a move
the engine doesn't really appreciate but
i thought it was quite creative and we
went through it greg also was dissecting
the position trying to figure out what
he could do
he plays knight f6 and guess what that
e4 pawn not being defended is quite a
big deal here because if your knight
takes on e7
perhaps there's just queen takes e4 with
check and black is
right in this thing where it's just an
awkward looking set of moves for white
what is this configuration by the way
with two knights on d4 d5
two bishops b4 and b5 i've never seen
something like this before and i don't
know what it's called
it's amazing how often that happens even
to experienced
players and professionals who've played
chess their whole careers it's like
how is it move ten and i can safely say
i've
never seen a position remotely similarly
this in my life uh
we're gonna have to come up with a name
for that by greg quickly
takes that knight on d5 he cannot castle
because if you play bishop takes e7
rookie eight is the response pinning and
winning that bishop or winning other
material
if white tries to save the piece because
that pawn on d5 that's stuck in place
you don't want to move that the g2 pawn
hangs behind it but grey actually
decides to take the bishop on b5 a move
that i don't love because i thought he
could have castled safely but he is
just trying to get rid of some of
white's aggressive pieces
and careful of bishop takes b2 um bishop
takes b2 if i
throw that on the analysis board i think
we have just queen e2
um hitting the bishop hitting checkmate
there's also knight d6 winning the queen
so
a lot of fun moves can still happen here
so uh
basically that's why we saw both guys
get castled immediately robert they're
like man enough of these tactics and
calculations
if we're just castle you know
everything's going to be okay agree
agree and they both get castle
and levi just is neglecting this pawn on
b2 or
maybe saying he's offering it please
take that thing greg does
and i'm looking at levy's reaction just
trying to see you know his response
because
did he do it intentionally based on his
body language i don't think it was
really intentional i think it's just
something that you couldn't take it for
so long so you just continue leaving it
there
and now that it's gone you're like wait
a sec can i can i get that one back
because
black has an easy routing of the knight
knight d7 to c5 or e5 the c4 pawn
is a clear target for black to start
putting pressure on and i don't see how
white gets after black's king soon
enough to make it worth it
you never know the value of something
until it's gone robert the pawn on b2
how badly would he like to just play
pawn to b3 right now guarding c4
and i mean this just looks good for greg
there's gonna be
easy moves to play brook c8 hitting the
c4 pawn it can't be defended easily
a6 hitting the knight on b5 that guy's
gonna have to retreat
the knight to d7 indicates knight e5
knight c5 so
i'm just seeing a position with a lot of
easy moves uh for greg to play the only
thing that i'm concerned about
uh or i would be careful of in his shoes
is if you if you play that knight into
let's say c5
or the wrong square there might be a
knight takes d6 uh trick with a loose
bishop
good thing to point out there and he
plays rook c first not
moving the knight trying to figure out
where does it want to go e5 or c5 the c4
pawn
is a weakness levy down to 20 seconds
greg at two minutes plus
another situation where levy being down
the clock is not doing him any favors
but greg playing well to his credit yeah
this
this is uh i wish i could announce that
as
a big surprise like oh my goodness
levi's at 20 seconds and greg has two
minutes but
it's actually more like you know simply
that the daily news you know
this has happened before it's going to
happen again in this match
uh we've seen it benefit levy and
benefit greg in the match so far
we'll see what happens in this one okay
well he kicks the knight back
now i'm looking at 95 to go knight d3 or
win the c4 pawn
both look quite appealing and it takes
away the c6 square from the knight that
just went to d4 so you're doing
everything at once and knight d3 is such
a big threat forks four pieces
it could it barely gets uh better than
that knight d3
covered by queen e4 but hang on that c4
pawn is also loose
i'm not sure being a rush to take it
though as move knight c6 is in the air
um i think it probably can be taken yeah
you can take it knight c6 bring your
knight back to e5 but then it starts
getting tactical
you start worrying am i giving levy
unnecessary play
and perhaps you can you know he does
take it i was gonna say perhaps you can
find
an in-between move something better to
do greg says now whatever let me just
grab
that thing knight back to e5 yeah
instead of b5 supporting the knight um
it looks like greg is interested in just
simplifying
but if if levy gets you know knight c6
pawn takes
c6 at least that's one small thing that
that he can try to push
that cpan is his saving grace and you
don't want to allow bishop takes e5
if you're greg because then you can't
get rid of the knight in c6 so this is
what we've seen
a trait of pieces and well greg can take
on f6 but then that pawn gets into the
c6 square
he can also consider a move a night move
but the e7 pawns hanging and
i don't really want to give back some
material so i guess you just take on f6
and deal with the pawn being there but
it doesn't look very pleasant
no i actually might play knight e5 here
um i can't
really can't really tell if that's gonna
be worth it but i feel like if
um we're gonna play an end game with
queens rooks
uh greg is up uh two pawns here giving
one of them back
to play that end game looks a bit better
than allowing the pawn on c6 as you
mentioned like
i and he does play an 85 i don't like
that pawn on c6 so i really agree with
his decision here
and he can just play rook d8 take on e7
we swap queens i take on d5
i'm of a pawn end game no risk you've
1.8 seconds he barely got that move up
haven't even been looking at the clock
but he is just
making these moves in the nick of time
and after e6 two extra pawns for greg
he should be able to convert this yeah i
uh h5 is just hanging as well rook takes
h5 is the simplest rook back to d5
and there's there's no no
shot that levy holds this one h5 played
no he's down the clock and craig's moves
are easy a5 e5 b forged
keep pushing things there's no risk your
king is very safe on g8 in fact it's
white's king and it's about to be in
some big trouble
yep yeah queen d2 for example queen d5
it's funny we've
seen this queen and rook end game before
all the way back in game one f2 is
hanging
h4 i mean the position just falling
apart yeah rook h5 there's got to be a
mate here
something to h2 queen g1 check picks up
the queen he goes this way
and greg shahadi evens the match up yeah
and this this time pressure is
it's just not going to be okay uh going
forward it looks like greg has sort of
grounded himself
right the first couple games were kind
of high octane high pressure
and he sort of calmed down and said look
i'm going to play against
my opponent's maybe main weakness at the
moment which is time pressure
use it against your opponent he's
identified that as a weakness something
that he can exploit
he's going to try to stay consistent and
he has been playing quickly
in the opening phase of every game so
far and i think it's
something he's doing very intentionally
and that's why the evaluation part
after the opening or in a position with
so many piece on the board
can be very misleading sure the
objective evaluation looked very good
for levy
in that last game but there was no easy
way to go forward there was no clear
tactical opportunity nothing of the sort
and once greg was able to castle and
guess king safe he then quickly
snagged that pawn on b2 went up a pawn
and never let it go so now that we're
in game five it's two to two with the
white pieces i once again
like greg's position but that's also
because i don't play the character from
the black side
and with the open e file to work with i
think all of white's pieces being on
quite good squares it just seems like a
slight advantage for white at the early
stages not that anything
major has happened i just prefer these
positions from the white side
yeah and uh you know the evaluation bar
right around the middle there
right around even which is pretty much
reflective of this
this position right here we see knight
to c1 knight to d3
uh before the move f6 you might be
thinking oh let's go knight e5
create some pieces control that square
but levy has made a
clear indication that his plan is to
play for e5
uh he wants that as a long-term idea
however uh before it
e5 happens and before it appears on the
board you have this pawn on f6 which
doesn't make the bishop on g7
look great at all so if he doesn't
execute this plane with the e5
as white is you know gathering all his
forces to stop that
then he could just be weakening his pawn
structure and that's going to be the
fight for the rest of this game
and look at this position how many
pieces are hitting the e5 square i'm
counting
five for white and then there's
three currently but the fourth will be
the rook for black once e5 is actually
played
so even figure out if e5 is possible is
a nightmare it hurts my head
to consider it like i think e5 is bad
right now but i'm just more assuming
than actually
calculating piece by piece yeah we we
can't uh we can't have too much math
involved in in chess you know it's a
little too much to work on at once the
rookie two and
you know what robert i think he might be
trying to make it clear to you after
rook a to e1 that it's definitely
not possible to play e5 yeah that would
appear to be the case so what
can wow g5 so he's trying to kick the
bishop but if the bishop goes back to h2
i wouldn't be surprised if he plays h5
and then he should
try play g4 and kick the knight after
out of f3 whereas the knight
f5 is very strong i love this decision
by levy that is hard to play
and he did it quite quickly so i'm a big
fan of that
yeah um and after g4 you might even see
g3
afterwards e6 he just shores up the pawn
on d5
the knight and also puts the pawn on e6
so that maybe
white can't use the e6 square himself
and look at the pawn structure those
knights on d3 and f3
they're rendered kind of useless they
are defensive pieces and that's why the
knight went back to d2 wasn't doing much
on f3 didn't want to
allow g4 with tempo but the b6 pawn
takes care of c5 the f6 pawn takes care
of e5 and g5
and black's knight in particular the one
on f5 is very strong here
if you ever do play a g4 g3 or if you
sack
your knight for the two pawns in the
center which he does and then you take
the rook it's
a really nice imbalance of it's going to
be a rook
for uh sorry a rook in two pawns with
200 pieces
among whose position would you prefer um
i think
i think i would actually probably prefer
white um
seems a little weird but uh f3 king h1
you know bishop g1 if necessary because
e5 is going to make the bishop on
h2 look pretty bad i'm just concerned
about the light squares here
for levi i might like his position if
maybe some of these pawns
were back on h7 and g7 and the bishop on
f8 but
because the position is so open i i
think that the knights are really going
to have a field day
on some of these weak squares and that's
a fantastic move f4 just
highlighting your point hey the opening
of the position more pieces to attack
with sounds good to me
and this pawn on h5 would love to go
back just one square to h6
to keep the king side safe and sound but
if the gf4 knight takes f4 now h5 is
under attack
e6 under pressure the d5 pawn as well in
some cases so i really like that move
by greg to play f4 yep
yep this is a really really strong move
you highlighted
all the points about it so no need to
mention anything else but
levy i mean he's sort of realizing
slowly but surely
everything you just mentioned as well
he's coming to terms with the fact that
well
this is not really what he wants but how
is he supposed to do anything about it
right now the e5 square
belongs to white and i think that's
that's enough to say that white has a
very very clear advantage
a huge advantage at this point i mean
just look at the squares we were talking
about how the pawns restricted the
knights
that one pawn leaving the f6 square
allows
not just the knights bishop e5 was
possible followed by knight to d4
bringing all your pieces into the attack
this should be sufficient rook f1 queen
takes h5
oh this is no fun for black yeah the
only
thing that i don't really like about
greg's move and i was thinking maybe
bishop e5 would be a bit better is
there's a lot of background checkmate
issues with the king and bishop like
that
and you know if you play bishop g3
there's always h4 to consider so
i feel like this bishop is a little bit
trapped for my liking and
rook f1 is not so easy to to get because
there's either my queen takes f1 or
queen e4
and while he takes on h5 and rook comes
to c2
this is starting to look a bit scary for
that king on g1 i see the eval bar says
white is
just in cruise control at this point but
i'm not sure what that move is because
i would be concerned he plays the calm
bishop g3 and that takes care of the
back rank problems it covers the f2
square
maybe that's all that greg needed was
just to stay composed and make a very
simple bishop move
yeah i know i saw the evaluation bar
kind of tanked down after that move but
bishop g3 is the most logical move to me
watches over
e1 rook the f2 square it allows the king
to go to h2
so i thought bishop g3 was a fantastic
multi-purpose move
and how to press forward from here i'm
looking at knight e7 checkmate
so knight g6 hits the rook and threatens
the fork which is actually a mate on e7
that's one idea
that i have in mind here i guess i could
go knight c6 if for some reason that's
the better square
i'm not sure if moving the knight at all
is a good choice because black can just
respond with work f7
to knight g6 but then maybe the other
knight gets into e5 so perhaps it's just
time
throw your knights forward yeah king
something like uh king or not sorry
knight f2
knight g4 king h2 those are the those
are the type of moves i'm looking at and
rook
excuse me rook d1 and why did it go to
minus five it must be g4
just because the eval bar there's a
tactic you cut the queen off you attack
at the same time
i mean that's a very easy thing to
overlook i didn't see it until i saw
the eval bar go crazy but brookie and he
does find it levy
so so clutch when it matters that move
is i mean i'm waiting for the greg
reaction
um move is going to put it yeah yep
disappointment in himself and levy you
see the head shake there he's like yup
this is my game now
the the the ever expressive craig
shahadi
yeah he is not moving around too much
but this was his game and that move rook
to d1
which you didn't like even before we
talked with the movie g4
it felt a bit slow whereas he could have
rerouted his pieces and gone for it more
of an initiative and now he's
well he's suffering the consequences
yeah and you know for
for people wondering why this is such a
knockout move
um white has to trade the queens because
the queen's under attack
and instead of recapturing the queen
you're gonna take and actually
i made the move but i think it just
appeared on the board so it's uh
there you go you get to see a live
demonstration of why uh
why it just doesn't work and i'm trying
to think of the match situation so levy
will take a one game lead there's still
21 plus minutes in this longest time
control
so greg doesn't need to resign or
anything right now sometimes you just
want to get as many games as possible if
this were
the final seconds of the time patrol
then i think greg would resign and get
another game
but because we're still so early on here
it doesn't make a difference brooke
uh to f1 here is actually
pretty close to a knockout blow because
of rook h1 which was going to be a
checkmate so bishop h4
more or less forced um i think i think
we might see something very close to a
resignation soon
yeah i would probably start with rook to
d2 just trying to get after the second
rank upon
b2 is weak g2 can be under attack soon
and white has no counter play sometimes
two minor piecing is two rooks
there are actually some things you can
do here there's clearly nothing
there's nothing to even attack if you're
looking this from greg's perspective
yeah uh don't know about them if bishop
takes e5 to be honest but
i'm sure levy is not too concerned these
pawns are doubled
uh the king cannot even be attacked or
it's not going to budge from in front of
the g pawn
and black's just gonna take out the
vacuum cleaner and
suck up all these pawns a2 b2 and then
even g2 there's just no way to defend
and
you know the past pawns are going to
push right you don't even need them
but you can take them if you want you
can play d4 d3s or pushing
your pass pawns without grabbing more
but levy
kicks the knight out of the center first
and now the d-pawn i guess the d1 can't
go you can
that's how you lose your pawns i'm just
like there's got to be something here
this should be easy
and levy down to 20 seconds of course in
such a dominant position i'm not worried
about his time
but that could happen where you see down
to 10 seconds and you haven't won the
game yet you get frustrated
but no this is levy's game yeah this is
over
um the pawn is going to go to d3 and
then d2 is sort of the last chance to
stop that thing
bishop g5 is an idea but remember
there's still g4 hanging
and after you play d2 and you know white
sacrifices a piece it's gonna be two
rooks against one single piece
um this game is definitely definitely
over
for sure and plenty of time left for
levy he's going to take a lead
and i wonder what the mindset for the
players is like on the scoreboard you're
happy but based on the way that game
went
both players knew that greg was in
charge before he
played his rook to d1 move so i wonder
how they'll reflect on this levy will be
happy about the score but about the play
that's my
essential question of mine right and uh
speaking of the play he
started with um knight c3 which
almost it's kind of a move you need to
think twice on greg is
thinking about move one there and he's
going wait a minute i don't want to get
tricked
by some move order because i you know uh
after knight c3 you played d5
maybe white plays e4 i don't i don't
know is that is that going to transpose
into some weird karakan all of a sudden
well speaking of move order and changing
things up greg did not play g6 on move 2
this game he must not have liked the
position he
obtained well we didn't like it the
engine said not so fast not good i think
bishop h6
do you know this lineman no is the short
answer
and the long answer uh definitely not i
have no clue
not at all well bishop h6 induced pawn
to f4
and allowed greg to develop his king
side and i guess he will castle quite
quickly he could think about playing e5
at some moment the bishop on d2
a bit awkward because the rook on d1
wants the length of the semi-open file
and i just don't know how to evaluate
this
yeah this is uh once again we've seen
some very unique positions
in this match already i want to say
we've sort of got this
center game um by by white
almost against the sicilian just taking
with the queen leaving the queen on e3
and
i was about to mention that usually in
these type openings you want to use the
pawns a lot
however e5 very very uh committal move
in the center by greg
you can see he wants to use that bishop
on h6 actually wants to
make use of the fact that it's on that
weird square so what's he going to do
here pawn takes f4 bishop takes a 4.
there's a funny tactic just like in the
last game was queen b6
in that event so you can distract the
queen and win the bishop with check if
white's not careful that's a funny one
right it's like easy way to blunder and
he starts with queen to b6
so he had the same exact mindset that i
was going for
but instead he plays queen b6 right away
but now white
can take on b6 if he so chooses that
does open the a file it
ruins black's queenside pawn structure
but opens the rook
or he can play levi can queen h4 and go
for the attack and that's what he
chooses
yeah i think this is very in line with
the opening um
queen h4 now bishop g7 i expect will be
the move because he can't really go
bishop takes f4 because we'll lose a
piece
and levy look at that this is almost
like the grand prix attack style
you play f5 after the pawn takes you
could take back but
that's not usually the plan you usually
want to get the pieces involved whether
it's bringing the knight out
bishop g5 and bishop h6 both look very
very tempting
and there's some weird ways and i was
going to say d5 is one of them to deal
with f5 you just want to
break open the board because look at
white's king side not fully developed
and the king is on the queen side so
baby black can be quick to attack
on that side of the board if e takes d5
there could be a knight d4 type of move
black's piece are jumping into white's
position and it could be uncomfortable
but levy first takes on g6 that smart
and now greg needs to figure out hey
wait do i open the h file which he does
or
take on the g6 square with the f pawn
which opened the diagonal which looked
too risky
for me it did look pretty risky i mean
we're on move 13 going on 14
and you're being quite generous there
robert by saying that
white's king side is not fully developed
it's not developed at all
he hasn't he hasn't had the chance to
move any of those pieces and again
he goes with one of the pccs already
developed so just going back to those
fundamentals i'd have to say that greg's
position has got to be great like
knight takes e4 he's trying to meet that
with maybe a knight
hit i think that d5 but i just don't
believe in it
and i'm trying the other move d4 is
possible but
he plays it requires a lot of
calculation bishop f6 d takes c3 i think
we understand
what black's going for so just go after
white's king
trading pieces not directly but still in
a good way for black and
where's that knight going knight a4 you
can even move your queen
probably just to b4 or something like
that to attack the knight
yeah knight a4 is just you know not
going in the same direction as all of
white's previous moves
so knight d5 would feel like the more
consistent move but hey day four
uh not not too impressed by
levy's position here however he is
playing a lot faster than we have
seen him play in the last couple games
and greg needs to be careful because we
keep talking about the lack of
development for white all you need after
bishop takes f6
queen takes a4 is knight f3 knight g5
and the game's over
so so it's a pretty quick attack that
said
look at that queen that's going to be on
a4 that means knight b4 will hit c2 with
checkmating ideas the a2 pawn
will be under attack i am not sure whose
attack is going first and if i'm seeing
the evaluation bar correctly is that
zeros yeah 0.00 which
uh basically means hey if you're a
computer
this is a dead even game and you know
what else it means
if you're a human this is not even at
all someone is going to get checkmated
it's saying good luck trying to figure
out all the tactics here
and that usually means that there's some
kind of draw by repetition somewhere
and b3 played that move oh gosh
that looks scary to my eyes and knight
h5 the
quick response by greg i i've that eva
eval bar went from zero
did a lap over to levy's side of the
board and after knight h5 went all the
way
back to the middle so i don't even think
the engine knows what's going on or what
to make of this position
are we finally going to see those pieces
develop there's bishop e2 i'm happy to
see it
but knight f4 such a good response
closing the
bishop on d2 is diagonal you would like
to trade the dark swordfish from g7 that
g7 bishop
holds together black's king side and not
only that if that knight is captured
that diagonal opens up
there could spell doom and knight takes
e2 check followed by d3
looks disastrous for levy right now i
think greg is just going to blast
through on the queen side
yeah this even if you don't have a
tactic like that this knight on a4 is
doing nothing i mean this whole position
is not something that levy is going to
be signing up for again but
definitely definitely need to do that um
knight g2
is that you're probably thinking of it
yeah wait a minute oh you can't play f6
the g6
falls yeah it doesn't quite drop the
queen but
there's a reason why he's not just
playing knight takes e2 right now and
it's because of knight
g2 because even if you don't trap the
queen you sort of discoordinate white's
pieces and knight e3 is always a great
square to come back to
wait a second knight g2 queen g5 king h7
threatening and if the bishop moves you
bishop h6 let's show them the analysis
board
oh it's just played so we don't even
need to happen
oh my gosh is king seven has to be king
h7 i guess
he could also be planning like knight e7
um with a
similar idea wow
but i'll show king h7 which was your
move followed by f6
guarding that g6 pawn that's that's a
queen trap i mean how how do you get out
of it remember if you move this bishop i
can barely move it anywhere but if you
move it back there's bishop h6 as well
and we're seeing this on the board so
king h7 was in fact just played
and that's the added bonus of putting
the king on h7
is that you can get the h6 square under
your control i think that
greg is is he trapping the queen is
there any way to even save the queen
that's the most important question right
now
bishop h5 wow that's creative and
actually
if you take it that black king now could
get in some trouble the knight on g2 is
a little awkward but yeah like take cake
knight f3 maybe has to be
good for black it has to be fantastic
for black
yeah there's there's no way there's no
way
but i i think you almost have to play
bishop h5 i mean
it's like imagine you don't develop a
single kingside piece and the only one
you develop it's like
yeah all right now i'm just going to
send you over here into battle to die
immediately and
gotta save the queen long live the queen
but unfortunately
you're giving up your other stuff and
then even your idea from earlier
with some kind of maybe like knight d8
to e6 can i just leave your bishop there
yeah it would be cruel here to be a
threatening f6 and just not play it just
play bishop v6 just develop
yeah oh my gosh and i was trying to get
the knight to e6 to trap the queen
anyway because like knight d8 to e6 is
available
but i'm guessing you can even just
capture on h5 and that's that but levy
spending a lot of time here trying to
figure out a way to save the queen
unfortunately even if he manages to do
so probably doesn't have enough time to
save the game yeah there's uh
he's this is more of a frustrated uh
type of thing a g3
you know that knight takes e2 is good
for black so you're not even thinking
about other moves that might be even
better and knight you two just hit him
like a drug he goes
h4 and i think he has some idea to get
like a bishop c4
and go for some cheeky checkmate idea
robert but
you know that would be absolutely sick
but unfortunately
he goes knight of three so he's trying
to get that kind of checkmate
we will see the classic exchange of one
pawn for a queen
[Laughter]
oh my gosh it's actually kind of
interesting
so and do you have any other choice for
greg because
if i want to take the queen there's a
queen for a pawn
available to us and i think and we're
thinking
you have to avoid psyching yourself out
i'm pretty positive you can just take
the queen
and move your king back but it does look
a bit scary with that bishop c4 check
it's one of those positions i would just
take the queen because if i'm wrong
that's just insane you know like
yeah it's like i just couldn't accept it
he went knight d8 because he wants to
block on e6
once he does take the queen yeah
covering e6 f7
because he could give up some material
and we do see h5
not sure it's gonna be enough though
takes knight takes
and i think he can go back to g8 before
h not h
sorry but yeah g looks uh solid although
king g8 bishop c4
check if you take you go knight f7
there's h takes g6 so you
have to be very careful here
queen takes c4 give it back oh i love
that
give it back honestly wait what are you
you're up at peace so it's a good
decision
you did give it back did you see levy's
face by the way he's like wait what was
that
but black is up a piece i wasn't even
counting material
but this is a good practical decision by
greg
yeah i wasn't looking at the material at
all but
greg was smart enough to look just check
and say wait
do i even have to bother and how
frustrating is that when you're levy you
find this beautiful sequence to
get your queen back and the guy's like
yeah no problem
yeah that doesn't it shows that your
position was not very good
before that and all right the knight
comes down 97's mate
97 is checkmate and he is 1.9 seconds so
don't play 92 and take the rook on g1
you get me exactly
okay he's free up the f 8 square and now
his king can run to e8 and c2 is hanging
92 check
all that good stuff okay so he he he
managed there
how many rooks are under attack what
i want to know the accuracy of this game
because i feel like there's like nobody
knows
whether they played good moves
throughout this one wow i mean
what can we say robert you pointed it
out it was played on the board
by greg shahadi that was a sweet sweet
queen trap
knight g2 very impressive stuff and well
done by levy to even make that a fight
because most of us would just resign
when we see our queens getting trapped
he said wait a sec maybe i can get an
attack going
and then props right back to greg for
sacrificing the queen
instead of getting his king in any
danger so greg takes a
3-3 tied match into this seventh game
with the white pieces we've seen this
before bishop f5 queen e2
this was game one and i liked greg's
position in that one
do you think this is a good decision by
levy to go back to this opening
yeah i don't mind this i i think he had
a very solid game
um i think that he spent too much time
because it was such a solid position now
if you're gonna tell me you're low on
time
make it a game like the game we just saw
you know that's acceptable i mean if
you're low on time because your
queen is trapped and you have to come up
with like an artistic brilliancy to save
it
i understand but in this i think that
levy can get the same position
the same type of position he got against
greg but you can make some small changes
like for example h6
all of a sudden you don't lose your
bishop to knight h4 um
you know bishop f4 by him i like but
there you go b5 just these small
adjustments and
i really don't think that this is a
position he should be shying away from
yeah i was asking the question uh
genuinely and i think that he
has shown a very great understanding of
the
karakan how to play in it even when he
has less space it doesn't seem like he's
sitting there
just itching to play some moves that
would be a bit rash
so instead he just plays b5 takes
control some of the light squares on the
queen side that knight will go to b6
later
very likely but h4 is not so fast maybe
your knight is needed
in the defense of your king side because
i can use your pawn on g6 as a hook
and play h5 at some point to break open
the file
yeah and that's that's an important one
um greg is going to look to maybe
create the same structure as last game
g3
king g2 there's also a knight e5 move
which
isn't actually that crazy because if it
gets captured
all of a sudden we go d takes e5 and
white can start to push forward
on this uh this d file that black cannot
challenge because the bishop on
g5 i really like that move knight e5 you
suggested it greg
ends up playing it and you want to take
over
the d-file if you take on e5 which you
may feel
forced to do at some point then the pawn
takes the rook is open the bishop covers
the d8 square
and i would like to just plant a rook on
d6 and we can actually show that
uh if knight takes e5 pawn takes the
bishop e7 we just trade and play rook d6
and
good luck on that d file because i'm
gonna triple i'm gonna bring rook and
then my queen
and i would like to take back on d6 with
a pawn yep
yep and we we've seen earlier in the
match you know one of those past pawns
greg did not want to allow it in his
position now he's looking to get one
himself
pawn on d6 would just be crushing and
look at this i think if the bishop gets
taken he is going to
grab it with the queen so as to make a
threat on
h4 so i think that might be very
important
for the position good call and now the
question is how important is the h4 pawn
can you play rook d6 and give up h4 for
c6
it looks very i mean he does it it looks
dynamic i feel like
levy isn't too unhappy about this but we
have to remember that black has these
double g pawns so the c6 pawn from a
structural standpoint is more important
yeah i actually was curious why why
didn't play queen e4
hits the c6 pawn and guards h4 and then
just go rook d6 but
he decided to just uh punch it through
rook d6 he takes on c6 the b5 pawn is
hanging
and as you mentioned the structure those
double pawns means
hey you know we can lose the h-bond and
it sort of still feels
like it's three on three on the king
side so
even my material not so leveled by the
pawn structure white can create a past
pawn b5 is under attack right now
levy down a minute 15 seconds that's par
for the course at this point but plenty
of time left considering how many pieces
have been traded
and he needs to find a plan it's not
just about you know move like rook to b8
which defends the b5 bomb we can all see
that kind of move it's about actually
coming up with a plan after that because
white's pieces seem a bit freer in the
position
definitely and there's going to be you
know like moves like b4 is already rook
c4
forking the queen and the pawn there so
you can't just
simplify as easily as you'd want to rook
b8
guarding the pawn is actually one of the
only moves i can see
unless you go for a counter attack of
some sort like rook d8
queen takes b5 rook d2 is one way to
try to get something going of your own
but again white doesn't have to capture
that there's lots and lots of other
moves that can that can occur but
i think he's either uh yeah and he goes
rook d8 he was thinking about whether to
be
defensive or to be aggressive and look
at how quickly greg had that lined up
rook d6 saying this is the only open
file
we may have traded pawns on opposite
sides of the board but none of the other
files are fully open he'll play a3 he'll
just keep
that pawn safe he could play rook e to
d1 because that pawn a2 not really that
important whereas getting a pass pun in
d6
now that is consequential so i would not
be surprised and greg does play rook e
to d1
this looks really nice for white levy
cannot participate in those exchanges on
d6 he knows just how strong
that pawn is i mean they say that two
connected palms on the sixth rank are
worth a rook
but a pass pawn on the sixth rank
protected by your pieces that is going
to get to d7
i mean that's probably worth in some
cases up to a piece
yeah that's true and he brings queen to
b3 i like the way that levy is just
keeping
greg on his toes don't drop that b2 pawn
because then the rest of your queen
side's in trouble
greg plays g3 wait a sec can he try to
check me down the h file at some point i
know that seems like a pipe dream
but black doesn't really have any clear
plans here and king g2
rook h1 line the queen up on the h4
square let's say
that could result in attack definitely
a5 played trying to make uh b4 happen
and just simplify everywhere i think
king g2 is reasonable here i also
like rook d4 which just watches over the
b4 idea
but yeah but i like king g2 because it's
flexible you're there for the end game
you're also saying hey remember the h
file remember that pawn you took on h4
that might come back to bite you yeah i
do think rook d4 will be played just to
eliminate the counter play from levy and
i'm looking at the match clock
just over a minute left this is likely
our final game unless there's
a decision in the next minute which i
don't think is likely
so this position is one for the lead
if greg can maximize his advantage
here but for levy you see this situation
you know you want to play b4
what are some other ideas you can go
from a rook c4 to trade-off pieces if
the rook goes d4 and open the b
file i'm more worried about black's king
than anything
yeah definitely like rook c4 as an idea
to trade off rook d2 looks
a bit passive to me number one b4 is not
prevented
number two there's no more h-file stuff
right there's no king g2 rook h1 with
the rook on d2
all of a sudden you know those threats
that you might have been able to create
in the middle
queen side and king side well forget
about the king side for now
wow and this was an idea i didn't even
consider queen to b5
pinning the pawn so greg
allows b4 to take over the b file and
pin that pawn on b4 to the queen on b3
if rook to b8
why would play rook to b6 and keep that
pin alive and try to win the pawn
that was something i i did not see that
coming and queen c4
looks like just as good of a response
because
after you know this gets taken then
suddenly the pawn on b4 can get taken
i'm
a big fan of levi's response to their
queen c4 white goes and takes on a5
all of a sudden black takes on c3 and is
able to liquidate the whole game
be careful some of these rook end games
might seem crazy but
i think that levy might have the better
chance to win them um because
of the extended pawn on e5 something
like g5
and the king comes out to f5 in the end
game it's a
very very good point so if i'm greg i
would trade queens
take on b4 with my c pawn and then try
to launch
my a pawn get myself an outside pass
pawn that could be worth
even losing your central e5 pawn that
you mentioned as
being a possible weakness so that's what
i would go for if i'm greg but he's
spending his time
wisely here this is a very big decision
do i take the pawn
a5 and trade off the queens in that
manner do i turn on c4 and then try to
spring free
the a pawn like i was just talking about
and he does take on a5 when all said and
done
yeah and i think this is going to
simplify
pretty seriously uh greg might be
interested in taking that rook
putting it on a2 at the end of all this
is he gonna take with the pawn or the
queen i'm not sure it matters
um the queen would sort of force an
exchange which i think is why he's
chosen
and he's gonna get that outside pass
pawn whether or not levy can deal with
it is another story
but if the queens are traded the a pawn
will survive
and we'll try to just keep on running up
the board up to the a6 square
that would be the preference and the f7
pawn something you need to keep an eye
on and the e5 pawn for white so there
are different
weak points in the position and levy
down to 30 seconds a month he's got to
speed up
he's got to speed up i'm i'm just
wondering like is he thinking about
not trading the queens anymore no cousin
that's a kind of an incredible move
because i thought the whole point
was to take the queen and disconnect
things but the fact that he was spending
time there robert
did indicate to me that he was
calculating something and i think we're
seeing what that is he wants the central
e5 pawn
and he wants to say look with g3 played
there are some real checkmating threats
uh against your king and queen d4 very
brave move of rook c1 check
rook d1 we block off that rook and
there's no queen energy when checkmate
happening and 15 seconds for levy
he brings his king a queen excuse me
into e1 and after king g2 if rook c1
then white has rook d1 to block that
first rank even if it costs the e5 bomb
yeah it's just a move he had to play
however e5 will be
i'm sure it will be taken but a nice
check on the way
so queen e4 white has to decide where to
put the king e5 pawn falls
and then it's going to be basically some
past pawns against the activity and then
the weakness of the white king
oh don't take me to rook f8 and queen
days checkmate i was like wait does that
hang upon
no it does not we see a trade and i
would just bring my queen back to d2 the
outside pass pawns are stronger and
harder to contain and levy has five
seconds left
yeah this should be completely winning
it's funny how one move there gave a big
advantage to white i think it's actually
a big advantage for greg here no matter
what but uh
queen a1 blundering a pawn for no reason
so we spoke about greg having the
advantage and greg says not so fast
there goes my advantage and he just
dropped the pawn that was
and look at him he's shaking his head
that was a completely unnecessary slip
just making move without really thinking
about it with the hand rather than the
brain
and now i think levy should be able to
hold this but it's still in over he's
1.9 seconds when he made that move
1.4 i'm playing b5
yeah if white gets the queen to c6 then
it covers all the checks
but what is levy doing he's doing the
right thing he wants e4 and e3
he's scaring me with his club wait this
is zero seconds it's in zeroes
like this how there's like zero point
one
queen eight check and then b8 equals
queen okay he takes here first but he
can
oh he's not queen and queen d8 and then
he
and then he queens but king g3
is solid and that is the hanging queen
there
and wow i mean greg tried his best
to not win that game cleanly and
say he succeeded and not winning it
cleanly but he did win the game after
all
and he is pumped knowing that he's going
into the break
uh or or at the end of this segment with
the four to three lead he's pumped he
looks like he's about to pump some iron
get his crossfit session real quick
we're going to take a quick break and
when returned we'll come back with the
three plus one segment of this i'm not
gm speeches championship match
and just a reminder to all of you out
here who haven't been following from the
beginning where you been
but you see how each player has arrived
at this point levy rosman
took down james candy the third that's
gm canty to those
who know him and eric rosen in what was
an absolute barn burner that was a
tied match had tie breaks and then levy
ended up on top
and greg on the top of the bracket there
he beat alexandra in an odds match
he then went on and beat costa kavitsky
and now he's here playing against levy
so
based on what we've seen this has been
anybody's contest thus far amman
i think the players are living up to
their billing absolutely i think we knew
this was going to be a close match and
we also knew that
there was going to be a few factors at
play which we have seen already
the time pressure has made for some very
very exciting games
greg is seemingly maintaining his sort
of controlled style
but he has had to you know he's had some
wild ones he's made some crazy decisions
to try to
you know go for a flag in a position
where you should just take a draw
so i think we've seen a little bit of
the nerves and a lot of actually costly
blunders
by uh greg in this match i mean the
the blunders are just causing the
emotions to flow out of it
you know all those analytic heads and
prognosticators out there they like to
break this down into the numbers and
levy started up two to nothing so it's
actually been four to one
in greg's favor in the last five games
that's
clearly good momentum for greg but this
has felt like a very back and forth
match
despite the fact that it was a two game
lead for levy and that was a one game
lead for greg it just feels like the
players are
really right there with each other and
not much separates them
100 and that's exactly what we have here
as
you know four to three score line uh if
we get into the three minute portion
levy uh dropped under 2 800 as greg
jumped over 2700 uh uh elo
on chess.com blitz right just
stealing some of his rating points and
we have d4
and instead of these sicilian lines
starting with a close sicilian
now we have sort of a london type setup
with an h4
push what do we got here mom
well you know at least uh compared to
some of the recent positions this is
actually one i can drop a comment or two
on and
know what i'm talking about so knight f3
the idea
knight e5 if the knight captures you
want to capture with the bishop
and you'll have a nice pin on the f6
knight
so a lot of times you go for quick
attacks here
black ends up cast on king side white
can often decide to go queen side
so he starts with 95 the the idea is
basically
g4 at some point whether it's with f3
and g4
and you might say oh greg i think he
mouse slipped but
backtrack king fade is actually a move
believe it or not that gets played in
the system
yeah both players have studied this line
that's very apparent
and the rook on h8 is so necessary to
the defense for black because if
and when white plays g4 you have that
rook ready to meet that h pawn for white
so i like
how both players are handling this this
was actually seen at the highest level
between
fabiano caruana and anish giri in tata
steel masters tournament
not this exact position but this opening
so it has
a quite a strong reputation and it's
especially good in blitz
yeah and we see d takes e4 and almost
starts to look like that um
you know the same structure as akira
khan or scandinavian where the d
and e pawns have exchanged for one
another and bishop takes e4
i think hinting that after knight f6 he
might want to retreat to
f3 instead
bishop f3 can be played here he goes d5
just trying to break open the center
with a queen on d8 the rook typically
wins that stare down
on an open file and greg just takes
right back and
what do you make of this among because
i'm starting to believe in white's
initiative here
and yet i look to the side of my second
monitor here and i see that it's just
about level yeah the evaluation bar is
having a
tough time here but uh one thing i will
say is that
levy's position does seem easier to play
if the queens get
off the board then i really like levy's
chances i think that the
side majority here compared to um
black's two pawns is going to be very
effective
it's easy to just double the rooks bring
the queen to the middle um if the queens
stay on the board though i totally
understand that
there are going to be some aggressive
attacking chances coming from black
and that evil bar just shot up which
means that there's a tactic here
and i only see one i have no idea why
it's gonna work but that must mean that
bishop takes g6 works and this is
strictly because i see the eval bar go
up it doesn't go up like that if you
just play rook
h1 to d1 right uh there must and that he
plays it so
levy spots it e7 is hanging
rook g5 can happen if the queen takes in
g6 yeah this is just
i've gotta i've got another piece of
advice for you you know if the eval bar
is up there
and they make a move and it doesn't
change well guess what that was the
right move
and bishop g6 looks crushing here as
queen takes g6
rook g5 uh is going to be the answer and
if pawn takes then queen takes e7 so i
mean how do you
they even respond to a move like this
you just
you don't you just sit there you pause
you go
for head into the camera and greg look
at his face like oh i didn't see that
one coming
and this has to be bad but where is the
knockout right you have
two pawns and the attack for a bishop
but if you don't checkmate in the
relatively near future maybe black gets
out of this
i think rook d6 and queen g5
um would be my first instinct uh can
stop it with like queen b5
so that's the first thing i'm thinking
about sometimes it's even just a slow
move like
you know rook to e1 or rook to d1 and
then proceed with the queen
g5 and stuff like that but that's the
problem all of these moves look good
and after rook d6 queen b5 maybe that
changes the balance and all of a sudden
black
has some chances to escape i don't see
those the clear escape but it does look
like black's still holding on
and look at levy's clocks he's trying to
find that knockout do i throw in queen
g5 check or do i leave that for later
do i play my rook to e1 or d1 does it
make a difference
and he plays rook e1 and while the
evaluation bar still seems
pretty high in white's favor so the
answer is well it doesn't make too much
of a difference because it's a good move
yeah queen g5 and now the rook wants to
slide into e7 so
you know if you develop the bishop or
something there's going to be queen g5
check
rookie 7 and all the pieces want to uh
want to join
join for a check mating attack how does
black stop that because queen g5 rookie
sevens we're pointing out
seems very concrete and obvious so
rook g8 played trying to get king to h7
i like that and then he rook g7 to
follow
just trying to shield the king as best
he can
shouldn't work out no i think one of the
things that can happen
is something like maybe queen g5 rookie
7 and even trade the rooks
and eventually get a rook down to d8 um
at near the end of that line and
you know just paralyzing the the queen
side pieces for
for black so i like that a lot sample
line
something like this and like maybe queen
e7 you could throw in and like rook
e8 and that looks great and levy
repeated moves
because he wanted to gain some time in
the clock now he's down to 13 seconds
counting down he
i think will play rookie seven check he
just doesn't see the exact checkmate
and he does play rookie seven step one
complete
and he plays rookie five and look at the
eval bar back down to zero
or in black's favor somehow yeah i mean
well at this point do you just have to
get the bishop developed is that is
there a checkmate
on the board i don't think there is like
the king can hide uh miraculously on f8
imagine something like bishop to f5
trying to
think like a position like this there's
there's no mate
exactly it's hard to get the queen in
but bishop f5 you can explain rook takes
that five right away because the g
one is pinned so greg down to 17 seconds
and counting on he needs to find a move
here
and the bishop can't easily develop he's
down to 12 and counting down
what's he going to do rook a6 played and
that was not
a move that the engine liked at all
queen e7 between
f or e8 and rookie 7 to follow beats
yep this is just force mate here in two
or three moves depending
where red goes and it's going to be made
on either f7 or
h8 so this is one of those situations
where it's very
good that the players just play the next
game
and don't get to look at their mistakes
for levy like dang i just played a great
attacking game and we agree with that
but we have the eval bar off to the side
saying well you actually made a huge
mistake somewhere
that gave black some chances to get back
in the game but they don't know that
right greg doesn't know for certain that
he had a save
and levy doesn't know that he missed an
opportunity because it worked
exactly the way he wanted it to
robert that was a brilliant point but
i was focusing on the fact that levy did
something that
is news to me he he looked like he was
putting his opponent to sleep is that
is that like a wwe like i'm not familiar
with the you know the levy rosman
celebrations but
is that is that a trademark is that a
staple as soon as he got the win in
there you know he did the
he did the little night night to his
opponent i missed that but he
then played the french so i took a
little nap because i didn't want to look
at the opening because look at this
position from levy's point of view
he has his knight on e7 blocking the
bishop he he's the one with double pawns
white is completely developed rooks
connected no pieces that are on bad
squares
so yeah i think it was a bit early to
maybe rock the baby and early
celebration it was a very
nice game well calculated and i think uh
the point you were bringing up earlier
is definitely helpful um good
help uh let's say levy to think that
that was
a clean game um and that he didn't maybe
uh miss opportunities for his his
opponent to get back into it so he's
feeling good
chess is very momentum based after a
game like that
um we'll see how it affects uh this game
right here
great bishop one b7 just got to say it
that bishop was awesome
the pawn structure better for white
nothing weak in the
i would recommend king to b1 just from
yeah well i would say building habits
but that's
your series but it's good to get your
king
scoot it away from the center and play
move like king b1 just to defend
the queen side and have yourself feel
nice and tucked in
yeah always always a good thing to do
when you castle queenside
king b1 just make sure nobody wins that
a pawn and sneaks in for a checkmate on
a1 so
fish basics and long castle of course
the only way that levy
could castle in this game after rook g8
and well
well you talked about how good that
bishop was how about now
oh you know what i'm just realizing
because i was thinking about it now it
doesn't work
that after bishop a6 knight c3 was a
tactic for black because i wanted to
play it after castling like way it
doesn't work as bishop takes b7 as check
so you need to play that beforehand and
that's the problem with having your king
on c1 as queen a3 comes to check
and it's out in the open yep that's i'm
just showing that one there that's a
nice tactic
that's uh the chess player's mind you
know even when the the move is already
passed and
we're on to a new position you know
those chess grand masters can't stop
thinking about previous tactics
yeah because king b1 was just played but
before king d1 was like
what can black do here and i was
thinking about knight c3 but wait does
it work because of the bishop takes b7
intermezzo with check
and so then i worked myself backwards
like wait that was available
a moment ago and after queen of b4 well
we see the idea knight c3
is coming that's what levy is trying to
orchestrate here so greg takes
and maybe just bishop d2 kick the queen
away and
take control of the c3 square yep
um bishop d2 looks very solid here c4 is
always an option but
i sometimes have a tough time deciding
looks like c4 is going to be good
followed by like a bishop c3 idea but i
always have a tough time deciding
do you play c3 or c4 in positions like
this c3
keeps d4 under protection a lot better
c4 controls more squares in the center
it kicks the knight out but
you know long term you have to worry
about the the d4 pawn and also the b4
square
i guess one of the essential questions
is what is black's plan because we've
seen levy play the move b5
a lot in these keracons but do you
really want to play b5 with your king
on the queen side i know it controls
some of the light squares just feels
risky and queen d3 played
not just to scoot over to the queen side
but actually to attack the king side
that h7 pawn
is directly under attack and something
that's easy to miss and wait a second
can he actually go steal that pawn i'm
inclined to say yes
i wonder if levy is trying to go like
ultra aggressive
with queen takes h7 rook g7 followed by
c4
and maybe an idea like c3 and really
just try to full commit
to the queen side that actually does
look um look like a very easy plan to
execute
and c4 played first ah but that this
gives him the e4 score with check
if he needs it after queen takes h7 the
queen can run right back to e4
gaining that perhaps vital tempo and
then that h
pawn is pretty important yeah and it
looks like
uh you know sometimes we look at these
uh pawns on the side of the board
a pawns h pawns and they're always a
little bit less tempting to capture
because
you feel like you're going way off side
just to capture a pawn but
in this position totally justified the
h2 pawn is guarded by the knight
so there's no situation where a rook's
gonna ever end up on h8 he just takes it
goes back to e4
and look after taking a single pawn
robber it's like plus five plus six
uh according to the engine where does
the king go i guess if the king tries to
go to b8 you just can take on c5 and
open up the
d file for an attack okay rook a3
so rook e3 just bring my rook up go rook
a3
your king has made it yeah i i don't see
how you can get out of this
and 17 seconds doesn't help however even
with
two hours on the clock here i don't
think he's he's surviving this one
robert rook a3 and we see the evaluation
plus nine this is like you know you put
your opponent to sleep night night and
then you take an early bedtime yourself
i wonder if greg saw that and i didn't
see it i completely missed it but i
wonder if greg saw it and he's
just showing off his might on the chess
board in this game queen b7 now to go to
a6
looks pretty good well we will know if
you saw it because if you saw it
he's obviously going to do it right back
at least that's what i would do
when you rather wake up instead of going
to sleep you know someone tells you to
go to sleep and you're just
you annoy your parent yeah what's the
clap back i don't know
king v5 there's no way you should be
surviving here
but as always you got to convert these
uh positions the queen c6 looks like a
um a good start queen six takes away the
escape square the c pawn is pinned you
would love to play c takes d4
to take away the a3 square but you can't
and now just take the queen and
that's that yeah yeah that's actually a
nice
um a nice move there queen c6 the the
pin on the c pawn didn't look
that bad but it was very important i
don't think greg saw it earlier but he
did just take a bite of something not
sure what it was
so midnight snack looks like a
clear afternoon snack based on how
bright it is in his background
yeah he's uh he's got a very very bright
setup there he's
right beside the sun and
yeah i feel like there are plenty of
jokes to make of no shade for shahadi
but
we're not going to make those here
instead we're going to focus on the
chest and greg has the same position
that he had last time against levy this
knight coming to e5 trying to trade
on the square but black has not played
h5 himself so that's the
key difference so far and usually
if you just castle let's say bishop
takes if you somehow castle here
um h5 usually does hurt so you do want
to be careful of that that's why he
played h5
and he's also does something a little
bit different he's gone much more
quickly with a5
and b5 so he's looking to create some
threats on the queen side a little bit
quicker
than the last game which might dissuade
levy from
an early castle yes strange position
where no pawns have been traded you can
try to play
a4 for white to encourage b4 but who
does that really help
do you play e4 in the center to try to
blast it open he plays f3 first
clearly trying to push his pawns e4 or
g4 later in the game
and then knight can go knight d1 knight
f2 to help out on the king side
in the center and this king f8 move
greg is more than happy with king f8
from last game you know
i think he realized that that last game
while it was
a really good game for levy and it was a
crush it
wasn't a game where greg should feel bad
about his opening
clearly had a good opening it went well
he's happy to repeat it
and he knows the king f8 wasn't the
issue it was just a one move tactic that
he'll be on the lookout for this time
and so he plays back into a similar
looking position but the knight on a4
caught offside on the rim the tension in
the center
is difficult to fully grasp because do
you play e6
i don't really want to take on e4 but
sometimes you do that just to open up
the position bring your knight to f6
next
what do you allow here from greg's
perspective
yeah because um the other thing is that
if white plays
e5 then the move g4 is a lot easier to
get
it comes with a lot more punch broke to
g1
and there could be a lot of sacrifices
happening against the black king so
i feel like i'm not liking greg's
position that much here but
i don't know if that's a that's a fair
you know
characterization like i think greg's
position is fine but
i'm used to playing these positions with
the white pieces and used to launching
these kind of attacks
uh one thing i'm noticing about dtx4 is
that if you take with pawn
well all of a sudden knight f6 and that
g4 square
belongs to black that's why he took
bishop takes e4 but that's not the the
recaptured you'd normally want to do
well you have to remember as well that
the problem for greg last time was this
d5
breakthrough that punch was really
powerful and greg's queen is already out
of the way he can play knight f6 in the
near future maybe there's time for
bishop a6 bishop b5
that knight on a4 is kind of awkward and
after d5
well i just saw it in my periphery and
i'm looking now at this my second
monitor there
it says black is better i don't exactly
see why black is better but bishop a6 to
b5 comes to mind
yeah bishop a6 to b5 looks good i mean
let's hope there's no flashbacks
to the pawn going to d5 and bishop takes
g6 because
i'm i'm at least looking at the bishop
g6 a lot more now
after the last game but mission base 6
to b5 looks good
with tempo the knight on a4 if you ever
have to play b3 to defend it
and capture it that's total disaster and
you're completely ruining the queen side
yeah those dark squares become
blacks for the taking and look at knight
f6 played there could be a queen f4
check so you can take on e4 after that
if you take on c6 well that pawn
probably not surviving much longer
in the event of this kind of queen f4
and moves like that
so greg just finishing development both
about a minute and 15 seconds on the
clock pretty even there
i start to like black's position because
i think the king on g7 is safe and
in your mind you're trying to launch an
attack for white it just isn't easy to
accomplish
and again he's quick with bishop a6 so i
think he's going for the same bishop b5
um i thought that white was going to
have to play bishop d3 so that bishop d5
wasn't going to happen but
the knight can move to the c5 and b6
squares which is important you don't
have to play
b3 or anything like that so bishop b5
the knight probably will venture into
the
b6 well now it can't of course because
there's
no queen defending the square so what's
he gonna do now
yeah there is like a check if you want
to play queen d4 check
and queen v6 um that's one thing
the other is obviously just knight c5
move out of the way
there could be you mentioned check so
maybe think of it like rook d7
where you hit the queen and then be like
a queen e5 check
that could be something that causes
black some concern here
although levy's he's really thinking
right now and he's trying to
solve this position as he's down with 30
seconds
and it starts to feel like that knight
on a4 isn't so comfortable
yeah i think that after queen takes e7
here
um there's a move like queen f6 and
the bishop would be forking it would
like uncover a fork
on the rook on d7 and knight on a4 but
queen e5
is saying look you cannot play queen to
f6 because
of queen takes b5 and look at this rook
c7 by levy very good
tactical vision by him spotting these
things
instantly and now the queen needs to
move and it can go to d6
even though it loses side of the bishop
because you're staying attached to the
rook on c7
but i don't think you want to trade
queens on d6 that solves one issue but
creates a home
f6 does the same thing but also has
queen f4 check so i think
i think he noticed that and that move is
probably a surprise for levy rosman
that is a beautiful move because now
instead of having a weak pun in d6
you're helping your king find some more
safety
and the pawn f6 is easier to defend once
you get your king to g7 i still think
white is much better here but 4.6
seconds
that's not helping your cause no rook c5
very strong move here basically all the
pawns are going to disappear
from the queen side and that bishop is
just
it's clumsy it's it's basically can levy
with four seconds
execute what should be a win from from
this position
so what would you do for black you need
to be tricky so first when you figure
out where your bishop goes bishop e2
looks like
it gets trapped there so he goes back to
e8 and now quickly brings his king up
so i'd probably play bishop c6 try to
get a rook to e8
feels not good though it doesn't feel
great
um again the bishop has nowhere the
bishop is the biggest
um issue here bishop b7 brook c7
uh this is just not what he wants i
would probably have taken that
that bishop okay but rook d simplify now
you have some chances take h4
rook h2 put don't forget yeah
don't pre-move that but you want to get
rook h2 to happen and then push your h
pawn
ship to f5 okay so c4 incoming that's
the plan for white two seconds
it's a it's a bullet scramble oh now
it's just bullet for both sides oh
so he had that lined up sacrificing
there wait the king gets in the corner
rook c3 rook a3 would be mate but there
was 96 check
90 okay 4k four oh my what a move
what a move and it's even material but
black's king is more active
i like the way levee is playing that
he's got some good speed right now a4
rook c4 rook b5 okay rook b6 maybe just
oh take over terrible move oh no oh that
was bad
and can you get away with taking on g2
that's the question greg needs to sit
and think for a second here
i think it's probably a draw nonetheless
so he's just going to make it
rather than risking anything
both of those guys look like they're
they're sort of happy to come away with
a half point they may
feign some you know oh i should have had
better there should have had better
but you know at the same time robert we
know those time scrambles go and the
nerves
uh you know that were probably an
all-time high
and they split the point they also are
going to split because it is the
halftime break for them both sides
probably need to stretch their legs take
a breather that was
really exciting chess they both had
chances there
and unfortunately for levi he couldn't
quite convert in his time screen well
amman
any advice for the players before we had
a break
uh well keep doing what we're doing
because you know as a fan we're
entertained so i hope they don't change
that much
it's literally back and forth um the
score reflects that is a one point lead
right now
uh the openings i don't think have been
a disaster for
either player really there's nothing to
worry about there
obviously you could tell levy about the
time but we know that's ingrained anyway
robert so
we'll just sit back and enjoy the joke
enjoy the show
we certainly will everybody stay tuned
we'll be back in a few
and as you see on screen here the prizes
for the event
we are in the semifinals the winner
takes 450
450 split by win percentage and of
course a shot at the finals in the line
that is the big prize for the players
ahmad it's cool to see this format where
every single game
counts so even if you are losing the
match if you win a couple down the
stretch you
net some extra dollars in your pocket
yeah and i think that's what
keeps these matches so entertaining that
even if you have uh
some sort of blowout victory and you
know in a lot of other sports that might
make the match
not very exciting at all but here you
still have guys who can earn money
every single match so uh they're gonna
keep trying till the bitter end
absolutely and it seems like we have
liftoff so we're getting into
the next game it's a one point lead for
greg shotty we are back
to the caro khan he started with a
french did you see that
right went to break levy played a french
the game was cancelled
and now he goes to the caracan yeah it's
it's almost like uh
the french is uh not usually something
people want to do intentionally
so after some reflection robert you know
i think he realized that the error of
his ways he said you know what let's
turn that into c6
i don't see any problem with the kero
khan it's been working well this is what
i was saying before the break
i don't think either of these players
needs to change the openings that's not
where
this match is being won and lost yeah
and something that i've voiced a number
of times already is that i
prefer white's position but it's a
stylistic choice it's not
because levy is playing a bad opening
nothing of the sword in fact he's
playing it
very well it's just i've never been a
particularly huge fan of
the french defense and the caracan in
particular but he knows his stuff
he clearly prepared he's showing greg
that
you may have a slight edge at the
opening that's not going to determine
who wins this match and
i think black's fishing is fine right
now yeah i think just
bishop b6 here it's reasonable um
get castle if you're levy rosman and
if you're greg you're you're not unhappy
at all might get the bishop pair
um easy position to play knight to e5 at
some point
so i think uh the opening here is very
very balanced
oftentimes you see a sacrifice on c6
something like just castling here and it
is played if you want those uh
you know take on c6 here i don't even
think you can win a pawn but
a lot of times in these london-esque
positions you just sacrifice upon there
without thinking
that's true the bishop 194 not defended
which means that that bishop would have
to react
after the knight was out of the way and
the queen would be brought up to d6 so
the bishop on g4 is also can be captured
so it's a very
weird position of what to take or do you
leave everything
greg decides to capture and i think that
bishop
takes f4 i was gonna say yeah it doesn't
look maybe like the most natural because
you allow these double pawns but
because there are bishops of opposite
color and you can get that pawn up to f5
i think that gtx f6 is actually really
reasonable for black
kha taking advantage of the open file
semi-open file but that's the block's
edge and rook to g8 can happen
at any moment and white should move the
king at some point but greg says ah not
not now i can wait a little bit how does
black
exploit the fact that this rook has a
semi-open line
directly in front of white's king well i
think um you should move the bishop back
in the next couple moves f5 is always a
nice move because
you can control the e4 square and also
think about getting up to f4
with that pawn challenging the g3 square
and then there's a lot of opportunity
for sacrifices with the bishop queen and
brook all lined up
and hey he's even looking to double the
rooks so tons of pressure coming up
i think we're going to see bishop back
pawn up rook over and then it's all
about that knight on c6 currently
not doing anything need to reroute it
even something like knight e7 knight g8
knight to f6 call me crazy but i'm
looking at e4 as a destination
okay crazy but that looks pretty good to
me and i i really like the way you're
thinking about improving the pieces
we can go for the brute force method of
f5 f4 as you
had highlighted and look at greg playing
knight h4
is that like coming back to g2 or is the
queen coming out to h5
i don't see how he's truly benefiting
from this and at some moment
he may have to even play an idea like c4
not one that you really want to play
that badly
but just to get some semblance of play
for your pieces
yep yeah c4 is i mean look at those
pawns they're always best
like b2 c3 d4 they protect one another
but
c4 as you pointed out might be necessary
where does white play otherwise
like if you're not playing on the queen
side or in the center of the board
the king side definitely belongs to levi
in this game so 97
he's starting to reroute but um i would
have preferred probably to move
uh f5 first i'm not sure if it matters
though
i think it does because queen f3 here
hits the bishop a second time
and if the bishop moves the f6 pawn is
quite vulnerable so he plays queen h5
also a good looking move but perhaps he
could have won the pawn f6
yeah that's a that's a small uh
difference i guess in position but it
matters a lot um
i think he's got a chance now though to
basically undo his previous mistake
either play bishop d6 or f5 and just you
know get back to and yeah he does play
f5
and i think levy's position is just fine
again
it is the clock is something that i'm
keeping my eye on because
while black may objectively be fine he's
spending quite a deal of time to get
here so
greg's king is quite safe it's not the
safest king i've ever seen but i'd like
king h1 in the near future if that
bishop moves
he can even consider pawn f4 just to say
no f4 for you
and you control a lot of the center so
he does play f4 the risk
is if your ideomon knight g8 knight of 6
now you can't kick that knight out with
a pawn that's my plan if
if i'm uh levy here especially because
there's not a lot of time
left then i want to go knight f8 knight
d7 knight f6
94. it's just an easy plan to execute
and one that doesn't take a lot of a lot
of calculation
and i have no idea what white does here
maybe knight e1 knight f3 knight g5
that's one idea that i can
consider but otherwise i'm struggling to
find an exact idea
definitely well i i think 91 is a great
move he does it knight f3 looks good but
you know what happens after knight f3
got to watch out
for stuff like bishop takes f4 and in
fact bishop takes f4
now with rook g1 mate ideas robert so if
you take f4 knight takes at 4 i know i
can't capture net 4 with my rook but i
can move my queen away
and i secure two minor pieces for rook
and two pawns we've seen
that trade-off earlier in the match
where greg had a great position and then
lost it but he says no i'm just not
opening my king anymore and he goes
knight to g5 and
what's happening here three seconds 4.9
now for levy
i don't really like that decision by
greg
but uh i understand why he did it looked
really really scary there to accept the
quote unquote sacrifice bishop takes f4
um
i guess he's saying that this position
is just going to be easier to play
knight h3
this looks just like you're down a pawn
and a very important pawn at that
because the pawn f4 helped your king
feel safe neither king will never feel
safe so
25 seconds for greg not that much time
for him either that's a fantastic move
as well rook g6
threatening rook to h6 which just traps
the queen
and even if it doesn't trap the queen
it's going to be hitting that knight so
queen h4
i mean you do not want to play that move
trust me but
he pretty much thought he had to his
queen was getting trapped i wonder if
there's a trick that greg can line up
because 1.8 seconds left for levy he
barely got that move often time
cannot move the knight from h3 because
rookie one's mate and what is he a five
wait what now rook wrote back to f1
there's no way no way he meant to do
no i think he did i think he thought he
was trying to get checkmate because he
has no time on his clock
but i don't even think white's worse
anymore uh i
definitely don't think oh there's any
more there could be some kind of oh
don't move your knight because we're
gonna choose checkmate
okay it's not checkmate because the
bishop rook 65 nice find by
wow he found that with no timing how
does he
he literally had no time on his clock
but yet he is
getting out of this oh my gosh
i do not understand what's going on here
that's me
in one i understand that that's about
all
but how did he find brook takes h5
and rook g5 check with as you said
literally
no time on his clock he's just seeing
the tactic he's doing a really good job
when he's under duress that honestly
sounds
counterintuitive because if he's in time
trouble shouldn't he be playing worst
chess
no he's been playing really really well
with the waning second so
now we have a hashtag teamscandy john
bartholomew i know you're watching
so come on type in the chat we know
you're here you should be thrilled that
your arch-nemesis greg jihadi
went into your opening now there's
there's only one place that
uh john bartholomew is when these
matches are on and it's in the chat for
every single one
we know you know you're right that's
john come on that's why he didn't play
that he could watch he had a much better
time
being on the sidelines here and look at
this move b4 from levy
sacrificing the pawn so you can get the
e5 square for your knight you can play
rook to b1
to use the semi-open file to attack the
king on c8
this is how you take advantage of
black's play
is there are no pawns out for black all
of them are on the seventh rank
so you don't really control many of the
central squares so b5 will kick that
knight
next move yeah it's such a weird type of
position to have
where you don't have any pawns in the
center like both sides are sort of
refusing
to play e5 and d4 despite the pawns
being available
yeah and honestly i thought it was
black's turn with that opponent before
but it turned out it was levees and he
spent
nearly 40 seconds and now he's playing
us
kind of two different ways he played b4
went aggressive and then played d3
as a follow-up and greg just snags the
pawn and says i can actually plant my
bishop on b6 later
bishop c or a5 bishop b6 and i'm going
to close down your open file
yeah and knight e5 wow with a hanging
knight
on c3 let's go hang another knight with
knight e5 robert
you're asking me to calculate too much
here so knight takes e5 rook takes b4
will be the response
does that help white does it help black
i feel like black king isn't in
that much danger just yet and look at
this the queen of d7 can be captured but
then the queen on d1 is taken next
yeah so i'm still wondering it's like
queen takes e2 or even the knight takes
e2 i think
both of them could be played here
and you know i see the eval bar in
black's favor i
agree with that i don't i don't think
that white has fully justified the pawn
sacrifice but there will be long-term
potential
because of where black's king is and the
side with the weaker king is
the side that typically struggles on a
blitz game great point yeah and
also being attacked though um levy is
going to have that
sort of blitz balancing of he's down
upon but
just being able to attack play
aggressive moves it's a little bit
harder to defend in blitz chess
however knight c6 i'm wondering who's
the one attacking because knight d5
knight d4
are easy moves to come in next and rook
c4 awkward placement but
maybe it's necessary to coordinate with
bishop f4 on the c7 pawn
you need to be up a minute when you
sacrifice a pawn like this not
down a minute plus and it's been the
theme of the day we keep talking about
this it's not going to change
and levy has been performing admirably
despite the
time deficit pretty much every game i
think that if you are greg here knight
b6 just sure up your king
very safe now both knights defending
then play on the king side
maybe there's going to be a f6 even an
h5 g5 push your pawns forward and
attack white's king yep that could
definitely happen
e5 f5 um you know and rookie eight if
you want to play a little bit more in
the center
or like robert said g5 h5 g4 can
crack open the queen side or the king
side rather queen e7 hits the rook
on c5 i mean i would at least be
thinking about rook takes c6 here
yes but i wouldn't think too long
because i only have 45 seconds left so
if you're gonna play rook c6 you just
have to do it go with intuition and hope
that it works
instead of bishop e3 which makes perfect
sense defending the rook
bringing another piece towards the enemy
king and is there no knight b5 hangs the
rook on c5
oh that would be a great move but it
can't work
close close there's there's a few things
that white is trying to line up here
like
knight b5 queen e5 rook c7
and uh right here i guess if f6 happens
there might be queen takes c7
or rook takes c7 as uh guess the rook is
just hanging
yeah i was going to say that rook is
under attack right now but your point
still
understands it's like trying to set up
the tactic here there's a hanging rook
robert help me out
yeah if you play queen d7 and protect c7
is an option and knight b5 is coming
there we go
this is looking quite a bit scary for
greg all of a sudden
yeah i don't know where this uh like
this initiative came from i think
it had to do with that knight from c6
that was the thing like keeping the c
file close guarding the central squares
i would have preferred to have that
knight on c6 instead of d6 where
now i almost prefer levy's position oh
look at that move
knight d5 it looks like c4 would kick
the knight out but the rook on c5 is no
longer defended because the queen on e5
is cut off so
this is getting tricky levy down to 13
seconds left
he takes the a pawn rook a5 but all of a
sudden white's pieces are in really long
places oh and then 96 to follow nice
don't take that rook do not take that
rook
[Laughter]
a6 it didn't even take a pawn you would
have thought that you stole a pawn for
the tactic but no you just put your rook
on the square
whoa brook d6 i mean this is a
insane position i don't know what we're
even looking at here it's almost like
white
thinks that black's position is his
position like he thinks that's his side
of the board
yes and queen takes g7 you guys
overtakes a6 and after queen takes rook
king takes knight
you're up a full piece it's no surprise
to me
that those two uh pieces behind enemy
lines there robert actually did in fact
uh go down
yeah they were in awkward territory and
this is what happens when you're down
so much time it's been working out okay
for levy and plenty of the games
but sometimes it comes back to bite you
yeah
one thing he does have is a queen d4
check something to keep in mind
um just to activate that queen back
queen takes h7 also hits the knight it's
not clear to me where
that knight goes it has to be defended
so queen f5 hits the mate and then
there's a queen of three ideas there he
plays it going to h1
and he wins on time in addition to
position yep
that is just a clean game so i feel like
um
in this match we've seen like levy will
have a great
game followed by um kind of a quick loss
um and that's he's not been able to get
the momentum
really going greg is always there to
stymie that
yeah greg has felt consistent at least
in terms of the clock situation
not always the play he has made plenty
of mistakes himself but overall the
match
has been well fought there have not been
any
or not too many i should say crazy
blunders of just a queen hanging
and things like that we saw in the
roberto against lars match some
checkmate one on g2 that was hung and
all sorts of other things
this has felt much more stable from game
to game
and well we have another position where
i like
white surprise surprise bishop h6 i feel
like we've seen this in um
maybe another match as well maybe even
the last match we just commented with
bishop
f8 bishop g5 being a possible repetition
but no
levy says queen b6 i'm going to play
this like a french but
difference between this and a french
position is that bishop on c8 has
already gotten outside the pawn chain
given itself up for the knight which in
turn makes the d4 square a little bit
weaker
and it means you don't have that bad
french bishop but on the flip side of
things
is f6 is a typical french idea that you
can't easily play
without your bishop because the e6 pawn
will be
not just vulnerable probably captured so
that's the big issue
with losing that bishop is even though
you're not suffering with that
awful piece you can't make your pawn
break
true at bishop f8 i mean if that gets
captured
and it doesn't it's actually push it
back to d2 if it did get captured that's
exactly what levy wants he doesn't have
a lot of space
he wants to trade pieces and that bishop
on h6 is so annoying
that asks the question to the king where
do you want a castle like where is it
going to be safe
caslin queenside and castle and kingside
both look a bit questionable
and look at greg taking the knight so we
have opposite colored bishops
that knight on d7 not a very good piece
the pawn
d4 takes away its forward jumps the c
file is open
white has connected rook so that could
be good and where is that king going
greg says hey if you would plan to cast
kingside think again because
now you're g6 square i got sacrificed
right there
right um queen g5 i have to say just
looks really strange because of bishop
e7
that seems like black would want to go
back to e7 it looks
like not entirely obvious maybe that
you'd want to retreat in chess but
bishop on b4 is sort of blocking the
queen and it's always subject to an a3
by white so
i feel like that that's nice for for
levy to get the bishop back with tempo
but he's
he's not happy with it he says bishop f8
no we're we're not done
the the home renovations i agree with
you the queen to
g5 felt like a bad move it just gave
levy some free time and he didn't seem
to make the most of it but speaking of
time he's doing much better on the clock
this game his position may be
a bit shaky at least according to the
eval bar and well my eye is also
telling me that white's position is good
but he's doing well in the clock so
he at least can find resources to help
him stave off an attack
queen g3 hinting at bishop takes g6 just
as an idea
doesn't mean that necessarily works
there's uh sometimes just rook g8
is a is an easy response if levy can
orchestrate
like knight b8 and knight c6 without
there being a bishop takes g6
then i think his position starts to turn
around i think c6 is the ideal square
where that knight wants to be
you mentioned it's completely dominated
by these pawns i agree so i think we
need to
get that knight on c6 where it actually
does something and he castles queensland
which means b4 immediately don't even
think about it just push
your pawns your rooks on b1 what's it
doing there hey
it helps you thrust that pawn up the
board b4 knight c3 knight a4 pawn b5 i
think these moves
can be played pretty much in greg's
sleep and i'm not sure how black is able
to
fend any of it off and the one thing to
keep in mind
is that the bishop on h6 covers c1 um
it's
it's easy to forget that long range
piece covering
your access to the only open file so at
some point
i know it's going to be tempting for
greg to just want to play rook c1
just remember bishop is sitting there
sniping you from h6 so black
can actually get rook c8 as we see here
and he's going to have full control
and here comes a5 b5 say hey have the c
file
what squares you have not c5 not c4 not
c3 not c2 and not c1 so
you have none of these squares for your
rook and so b5 i'm just breaking through
checkmating your king good for you for
having the rook on c8
yep now this is uh and look how quickly
it happened b4 a4
and then the pawns are already on a5 and
b5 here
i feel like levy would not sign up for
castle and queenside
if you knew this position was going to
be you know the case four moves later
i would just play rook b3 next rook over
to b1
and that's what greg does the a5 pawn
have it that actually makes your king
even weaker
opening up another half open file for my
rooks
and yeah the f7 pawn remains a target so
your attention
is all across the board here and it
seems like white should be able to take
full advantage
yep whether it's taking on a6 or just
doubling up the rooks it all looks
pretty good here
i wonder what the continuation here is
for levy the knight on d7 is still
not doing anything rook on h8 not
participating as well
i mean e6
you said that with like oh i can't
really play that move but i might have
to
and levy has been doing well on the
clock in this game and
if he's gonna find defense he needs to
do it quickly to conserve time because
even if he finds the defense for the
next five moves that sixth move with
three seconds in your clock
hard to save the game at that point rook
f8 looks like a
look like uh i really don't know what to
do move right completely stuck
and maybe bishop b5 rook a3 no you've
queen d2 so i'm trying to trap your
queen
but your queen has the d2 square there
yes
yes and bishop b5 like i think he's
going to go knight b8 because
there's no other place to go rook c7 is
the only other other move but yeah
knight b8 looks more natural
hit the a6 bomb this is looking uh
looking tough bishop d2 maybe and then
just move your knight
somewhere i don't know where though
maybe knight a4 i don't really want to
go to a4
i feel like i would go bishop d2 just
just attack you do something
okay i'm moving my bishop immediately
away from the b5 square and going knight
b5 next
yep actually pre-move oh this is
an ip5 check and then there's rook a3
almost traps the queen you have the d2
square over k3 first drop the queen
nice when the knight was in c3 rookie to
trap the queen but
oh he resigned with .1 seconds left wow
he got the resign in
just in time amazing speed there by levi
to get that resign in
well that actually is incredible i don't
know if i've ever seen
quite that timing impeccable for the
resignation but in all seriousness
that's a huge victory for greg he goes
up two points
and now we have to start talking him on
if levy loses this game and
goes into the bullet down three does he
really have chances i would say yes
because of how good he is in bullet
but the question needs to be asked yeah
it definitely needs to be asked it looks
like as we look at the match clock that
this will be
most likely or almost for sure the last
game of the three minute portion
so um as we see h5 this is going to be a
very exciting game
normally you're supposed to sacrifice
here i wonder if he's going to go for it
because
when i see a move like h5 robert it
means that you're asking who's gonna win
this game can levy win this game
well at least somebody is gonna go
downswing in here the problem is
normally you sacrifice that exchange and
get that quick attack but the knight on
d7
is ready to take the knight on e5 and it
feels like many of your attackers are
quickly coming off the board
that doesn't end black's problems no of
course not but you want to just
increase the pressure he might even be
looking at a knight takes f7 sacrifice
to keep the king there
no he's too good to just give up all his
pieces for the sake of
attempting to attack but i do believe
that
at this point in time black should be
just playing rook f8 move the bishop
castle queen side and i don't know if
white truly has enough
for the sacrifice material yeah i think
maybe at this point you sort of admit
that
you you don't really need to go for an
attack or a checkmate
i think there's a positional approach
here as well just long castling
rook to h1 i think it's fair to say you
could probably expect to win that h-bond
so then you'll have one pawn and a
knight for the rook
and the position is fairly closed so the
knight is going to be doing work if b4
look for knight a4 look at greg so
quickly than queen b8 i wasn't even
thinking about that move i was
where does my bishop go d7 or e6 he goes
bishop can stay put queen b8
and is that queen gonna land on h2 to
keep the white rook away from the h file
that would be quite something i i i
think queen h2 would be
would be too big brain for me to
understand okay well
he settles on d6 he agrees with you but
i
really like the look of queen h2 keeping
the rook away
yeah rook h1 i like it though i i've
wow i would have probably even
considered taking
that queen um totally understand the
move queen g3 but
i've had a lot of experience playing
these positions where yeah you're down
material but
hey it's a three minute chess game like
uh
you know just having a good structure
having a pawn at night for the rook
one thing to remember is levy has one
pawn island
just every single pawn is connected to
one another they can all defend one
another
it's it's a position that i think he
could go for a solid approach to just as
well
yeah i agree with that and you can even
trade queens and just say hey i'm gonna
win one of your pawns back
and he's going for breaking open the
position he's saying
i don't care i need to get after your
king but that might be the wrong
approach
especially and i hate selling a broken
record look at the clock
yeah i mean a minute left so he's down a
minute i'm not a big fan of e4
at all um i really really liked the pawn
on e3
keeping everything uh closed covered
now it just feels like the rook is a d8
d4 i don't know
how we even defend that there's trades
happening with the bishops black's king
is very exposed but white's pieces are
not in a position to take advantage of
it you got a rook on h1 it's
not affecting a king on c8 and that d4
pawn is just in trouble the rook
just got to d8 it arrived to cats the
queen side says okay don't mind if i do
your pawn's in trouble and well if you
go 92 there could even be queen e6 to
hit the a2 pawn tonight so he plays d5 i
like what he's trying for here but it
could be a case of too little too late
and rook g8 just
precise move after precise move from
greg and
it could even be well i was thinking
queen g5 to try to trade but there is
f4 um in that position so
probably i mean queen e3 is a little bit
dangerous because you're thinking about
ideas like queen c5 queen v6 so
i'm not sure if the move rook g8 is that
impressive 100
though we're going to see f4 and we do
okay so where's this rook going for what
i guess to d1 but the problem with
rook d1 is now you don't really want to
take on c6 next however the threat of
queen
b6 or queen a7 i think that's more
important
for white's chances here and actually
yeah greg's
king quickly in some serious danger here
i don't think this is that bad there's
also knight takes b5 ideas
with queen c5 track and at the very
least you're not going to lose that
position it would just be perpetual
check
um so there's there's a lot of reasons
why i think levy is still
in this game however 22 seconds
right and i actually think the mcqueen
g3 just to
keep that queen tethered to the pawn on
f4 you do not want to allow black to
take with check
and then bring that queen all the way
back to c7 and help the king out on c8
so
whoa yeah that's not a move i was
considering
but brave brave
for sure i i think e7 was hanging and
then even just d6 afterwards
i don't think anyone is playing this
terribly accurately right now there's b5
and c6 that can both be captured there's
too much to calculate and if you take on
c6 the queen
jumps right back from g2 and helps out
that king on b7 offers a queen train so
queen e3 was the choice
and now oh my he was just on e3 so i
think he
maybe saw that he missed queen e7 he's
like okay let me try that again
but look at this e6 and now the queen
goes back maybe there's rook d8 like
rook g8 to d8
bring in all the forces and c6 is
defended by the queen oh that's a free
knight hanging knight
that's yep okay yeah
wow well he tried to go for queen c5
queen e3 queen c5 queen e3 but
to no avail and you spoke about a
three-game lead
greg now holds bad three-game lead and
uh this is looking dire
for uh for levy rosman as it's going
into the bullet robert with
massive lead for greg and the momentum
certainly in his favor
and levy is the much higher rated bullet
player i believe it's a 200 point rating
gap between the players
however in many of these secs we've seen
the low-rated player
benefit from the increment in fact when
levy lost
last year to international master teddy
coleman the bullet
where you would have thought teddy was
the huge underdog he actually played
quite well
so uh it's going to be interesting i
think levy has definite chances
but a three-game lead for greg shady
that could be insurmountable
yeah that's a good point i think uh
we're all excited to uh
get into this uh bullet portion uh
robert i know i am we
you know levy is definitely required to
make a comeback here
and both of these guys are looking to
book a trip into the finals
well we'll have to wait to see who moves
on to the finals we'll take a quick
breather when we return it will be the
bullet portion
of this greg shahadi levy rosman i'm not
gm
speed chess championship match brought
to you by trust.com
well here we see the players on screen
greg
looking very concentrated ready for
bullet his pillows look a little bit
fluffed in the background over there so
amman based on body language right now
do you think that levy has
come back potential he doesn't seem to
be his spritely self
yeah he's uh he's almost just looking
like someone that's
waiting for it to start it's you're
never going to feel that
adrenaline or rush until it's actually
underway he knows what he needs to do
it is definitely a tall task ahead of
him
he's got to take out the number one seed
coming into the event
he's down three games but i think if
there's like a format
that he feels like he can do that in
it's absolutely
in bullet um it really depends how he
starts
for me because you drop one or two silly
games early on in bullet
and all of a sudden the lead just
becomes insurmountable so
i think he's just uh just just waiting
for it to start honestly
yeah just get that first win you feel
like you have a chance let's show
everybody the bracket just remind
who's waiting in the final it is roberto
molina who has
looked like an indomitable force thus
far in the
i'm not jim speeches championship he
beat lars oscar hogg
who's a very strong player by seven
points
he knocked off lawrence trent in the
previous match and then of course in the
first one against alessia santoramo
so roberto waiting with baited breath
for the champion
out of the other side of the bracket
yeah this is going to be a
obviously very exciting conclusion this
match but we are excited for the final
which will be coming uh shortly after
roberto molina against the winner of
this
match right here it's going to be high
quality stuff from here on out robert
well i think from here on out we're
gonna see a ton of blunders because
we're getting bullet chests
any second now and that's what happens
in bullet no
shade against either player when i play
bullet i drop my queen
all the time so botez gambits galore
lots of fun ahead but if you're levy you
need to get off on the right foot
and yeah it may not be a win but you
just need to start feeling confident
again yeah and it's gonna what's gonna
have to start right here because he's
going back to the car con
greg is just so solid um he has that
right style for bullet i feel
matt plus one second is gonna help a lot
so levy we've seen him be
slow all day is he going to turn around
here robert we've talked about the
phenomenon a lot where
you know they all of a sudden just
clicks for some reason in bullet
um i think if he's going to put himself
in any position to win this match
he's got to be playing uh as fast as he
is right now
and this is actually the dynamic we were
discussing in the previous game with the
e6
square and not just the pawn because the
pawn is gone a problem for black there's
no light square bishop to
hold on to it and look at this by greg i
mean how can you
anticipate any winning chances for black
you're offering a queen trade you're
taking over the only open file
this looks like an amazing position for
white where in a classical game i think
that
you would say hey white can win this 50
moves from now
yep oh knight d3 here um
looks safe i mean it's 96 is still
reasonable but i i agree
knight d3 going into c5 or e5 you
mentioned you have control
i mean how much time is gonna be burnt
off the clock here
for what could still be a loss for levy
several minutes and there's just no way
to end this game anytime soon and
black can hardly move you're just moving
your pieces shuffling them around
and what's the actual plan i don't quite
see one
yeah this is very very unpleasant
there's h4
uh to to think about all the way on the
king side
then there i was about to mention rook
d6 rook e6 is another way to try to get
the the rooks involved
not pleasant and knight c5 now the
knight moved away from d7
incoming to e6 with a fork even if it's
not a fork you may still want to put
your knight there
if the king goes up to g6 then the rook
definitely wait
right f6 yeah and that just wins a piece
that should be game over and he finds
the tactic as well so this is exactly
what i was
uh talking about when i said that levy
needs to get a good start that
i mean that this is not acceptable he's
gonna be very soon
in that insurmountable territory that's
gotta turn around right now and rook
a3 is i i wanna say as a reminder that
he's not fully trolling with that move
is this some kind of theory because both
polaris moving very quickly
and g7 can be captured but then queen f6
and that rook may just get trapped
so what is this that this is
probably has a specific name but it's
also called the like i just learned
chess
or i'm four years old defense and it
doesn't
i can't even wrap my head around this
position because on the king side i like
wise chances
then look at the queen side in the
center the d4 square the b4 square under
black's control
and it's a piece and a pawn for a rook
i just i can't talk about this anymore i
don't know i'm not qualified what can i
say
bishop g5 he's already getting some
material back by the looks of it
you know what's funny after queen g6
bishop takes d8 he's probably thinking
about knight c2 but there's no rook on
a1 it's just gone
right normally that would net you in
exchange but not here and
okay bishop c6 take on f3 the d4 pawn
could fall
i guess that black is okay with the
position but i'm just confused i'm going
to be honest
mm-hmm rook hvac another rook left you
know what what i will say is that
if you're confused that means greg
probably is as well and
if levy has a strat i think it would be
hey let's get a position
where everyone's confused because i need
one of these crazy wild positions
to shake things up get greg a little bit
out of his comfort zone he's been able
to get his solid
um you know positional games and they've
been working for him so i don't mind
this for levy
no i don't either he's up a pawn now
he's solidifying c4a4
both defended d4 well protected as well
and now we're looking at a situation
where levy's down
under 15 seconds but has a big advantage
according to the evo
yeah all he needs is queen h6 uh king g1
there's a lot of
sort of slow chill moves you can play
here that look fantastic
and bishop g6 i like the rerouting from
greg the c2 square maybe the bishop will
land there and hit the b3 pawn so to be
careful about that instead
levy goes forward with c5 and giving up
some squares to
gain some forward jumps yeah knight b5
you know if you ever play c6 knight d6
for sure
but i'm not sure that i would say that's
uh very worth it as you see that
knight is just jumping around everywhere
looking to get to c4 and hit the a5 pawn
and look at that break by greg e5 now he
could play e4 but instead
takes and there's a d file that rook
would hit the knight but then
d5 is nowhere good to go in fact it's
sort of trapped and it's
yeah maybe that's why f5 was played to
give it a square there bishop back to f1
makes a lot of sense
and f4 brook h3 i mean
levi's just putting all his rooks on the
third rank 1.2 seconds up he has
no time and he's playing well
considering but he barely has time to
get off his moves
crazy wow great at night though that's
that very helpful knight takes c6 how
how is he doing this with just seconds
how did he do that
i was like he's about to lose on time
and then he just wins all the pieces
every piece well that that signs a life
from levy rosman
folks knight d6 he just won literally
all of greg's pieces
he he needs to play with 0.01 seconds
more often
and greg is doing the smart thing of not
resigning he is up four points
we are now under 19. minutes you play
these out till checkmate
because you want to use every last
second
there's uh some mating nets here with
bishop c6 96 but
he's just going the uh the the easy
route which is queen
that pawn and that will be mate in what
in a few
yeah i thought it was gonna be made in
one but it looks like
two yeah queen g7 no questions on me
where's the mate
there's no mate yet okay well i i think
it's gonna be
end up being meet in about 20 or 30 but
it should have been made in uh three or
something
at this point you'll take the dubs but
you have to look at the match clock and
this is wasted another
what 20 seconds or something so yeah
that's
in another second there one last second
to take off the mesh clock
yeah and every there's a there's
definitely a relation here i don't know
what the name for this phenomenon is but
every move that your opponent checkmates
you inefficiently
gives you more confidence it makes you
feel more okay about playing on
don't know how to describe it but every
time they mess up you're like oh okay he
actually
isn't checkmating me efficiently okay
let's waste more time yeah that's called
the hamiltonian
psychology profile i have no idea i just
made it up but
i get what you're saying it makes sense
and it is definitely a thing in chess
and well sing another thing didn't black
just
take all of white's pawns on the queen
set over here but then the h7 pawn's
missing it feels like
black should be happy and yet the king's
on the center for both
i don't fully know what's happening here
levi's been doing this thing
in the last like minute um of this match
where he just takes off greg's pieces
and puns
and it's it's working quite well you
know in chess i highly recommend that
strategy so
levy he's taking uh pawn from the b
file and the default he's gonna get a
queen trade as well or queen c3 if he
wants to keep the queens on the board
this is just amazing for for black i
have to say although i'm not sure i love
keeping the queens on the board because
some kind of like rook takes f7 would
worry me
it probably doesn't work out but i'm
trying to knight e5 rook f7 queen d7
check you
it just yep it's not happening it's time
for you know
brook b5 or rook b3 and greg can maybe
swing the rooks and
do some weird gymnastics with them oh
rook b3 is a great call
just rook left hit the queen on c3 i
think rookie through right now makes a
lot of sense
and at some point he does take on e5 so
where
is queen trying to go to h5 to take with
the pawn and that's why
levi took with the queen and now castle
queen side to save
f7 is loose there is rook hg
but um rook f7 is something
that's true i honestly forgot that that
pawn would be hanging there and
rook h8 king g1 then rook h6 other rook
to h8
go for the mate i'm just not trying to
accomplish it yeah i mean he's using a
lot of time here and there we go there's
the natural move and king g1 immediately
played
and what's the drawback of rook h6 it
looks
nothing nothing i think stop it right
maybe he was thinking of some rook takes
b7 trick bishop a6 but there is king c7
there and he's all
he's all covered what else can what
maybe rook
b4 to h4 just give up a pawn to stop the
checkmate
i like that wow what a find
i like that move and actually bishop h7
would be a threat if the rook went to h8
because the d7 square and
the black wait bishop moved somewhere
bishop f f1 f1
yeah bishop f1 a6 oh gosh
bishop
and greg shakes his head but he's gonna
play on just to
waste time but levy now with two
consecutive victories
he's working his way back in this match
yep queen before it's me
and look at that that was a deep breath
there and i got this
15 and a half minutes that's way too
much time for levy to mount this
comeback
yeah i feel like both players just
looked at the match clock there and levy
was like
wait damn i got a lot of time
it's amazing how rushed you feel when
you're down by four points and you have
22 minutes or whatever it was
and then now that you're down by two
with 15 i can draw this game i can draw
the next three games i'll still have
plenty
of opportunities to make this work and
we want to remind everybody
that it is the match clock so if you
start the game the last game with
even one second of the match clock you
still get that game going
so it's the game doesn't end on the spot
like in arenas
so right now bishop g5 greg's queen is
under attack you can't block with the
bishop on e7
otherwise you'll drop the g7 pawn and
this looks awkward to me
from black's perspective but this must
be still some kind of
theory based on the way they're going
yeah these days in chess you're pretty
much going to be correct if you say
something like
this is probably theory yeah you know it
looks
i've seen this in three games before but
this looks very bad for black
well the problem is that greg just can't
get his king out of the middle he needs
like
b6 then he needs bishop b7 then he's the
castle and
what is up with this move there's a rook
h8 and queen h4 is just game over
oh my gosh and levy's about to get his
third consecutive victory
and look at greg he's tilted what i
would do is i would lose this game on
time
not to waste match clock but to gather
myself i need to regain my composure and
look at his face
i mean he is really just super upset
with himself right now
and you need to take a breath while you
have 15 seconds to do so
yep and that's exactly what he's doing
so there's one thing i will say about
greg is that
we are seeing a lot of those experiences
that that he has
in this format and these type of
competitions come in here he knows how
to use the clock whether he needs to
take a breather whether he needs to
waste time
but now he's probably thinking well wait
a minute maybe i want more time on the
clock
because levy might actually be taking a
lead soon
nine f eight and a half anybody's match
and right now greg goes back
to the white side of this french defense
i've liked this for him all day i think
he scored quite
nicely as well and his knight c6 97
knight d5 it feels
time consuming and in the previous game
greg did put his bishop to a6 at some
point
we'll see if he repeats that but that
knight c3 trick that was what
was missed careful it could happen again
it was bishop b5 c6 bishop a6 that was
the exact game here
oh oh gosh okay he brings bishop to c4
though he doesn't play bishop a6
i wonder if he knew that that's
interesting um anyhow we we got a
position that
does look fairly similar uh however main
difference
bishops are on the board the light
squared bishops not sure i love the move
a5 i get the intention but it feels
risky considering where your king is
and that knight trying to go to c4
venture on over to that b6 pawn
there is h2 hanging is he you know is he
gonna take that one
i think he might
be so funny he does he grabs it they've
both taken that that h-pawn from each
other in this variation
and just bishop e7 if you play knight e4
there's always pawn five and the queen
goes back to
honestly a4 followed by b5 when's the p
so that's why greg won a four himself
wow just b5 c5 coming next the queen
enough three's under attack
this looks horrible for white and levy
is about to
well i don't say about two but he's
looking like he's well on his way to
taking his
fourth game in a row yeah i mean but
look at these pawns it's
it's going to work out for someone on
the uh on the queen side here it's
going to be pawn takes a4 queen takes c3
is a lot of decisions
you have to make quickly oh and i didn't
like taking on b4 from white you could
play c4 and lock that queen out of there
even here white has some chances but the
king's so open i would
certainly take black yeah there's also
don't forget about the other side of the
board
h5 f5 rook g8 um
i think black can can strike on all all
fronts right now
and king a7 just getting the king all
the way to the side but
is he trying to get rooked to b8 that
seems to give white some time
yeah keep in mind his d5 i mean he just
hung material there by the way
yeah yeah d5 check so okay d5
knight to d4 to follow trying to get
into the c6 square
yep okay he takes first now the e6 pawn
is hanging the rook on b6 is pinned
the bishop is very easy to go wrong here
for both i mean
c5 queen c5 looks interesting here
i want to play e5 but maybe e5 for white
i don't really see anything else ooh
that looks
that looks risky you have to play e5
ooh rook h does rook takes d4 rook takes
b3
oh that would have done the trick watch
out for queen effect
still rook b3 yeah queen of fates one
check
what's he doing well he's
losing another game that's for sure
queen takes e4
takes g2 as well
queen e2 should wrap up this game and
there it is
oh my and now it's 10 plus minutes
and even on the scoreboard and if you're
greg you're probably just thinking
oh this is out of my control but if
you're levy you you still need to play
the board not the opponent you've won
four in a row you're feeling it you're
feeling good about yourself maybe you'll
do the
nap time gesture again but you need to
make sure that you don't get
cocky because yeah of course greg is a
very strong player
yeah and the thing with bullet is
somebody can just wake up and
you know win a couple games in a row
that's just how it works um
especially if you're just crushing
someone over and over
are you going to keep doing that you
know i it really depends uh
how the mental is um greg right now he
might
with the match tied if levy takes a lead
he might start playing a bit better
sometimes that happens where instead of
being so solid you actually play
you know in the position play actively
and with success so right now
taking on h5 this seems to favor white
castle queen side rook d to g1
try to kick that rook from h5 play f4
perhaps and
push the f pawn so i like white's
position here
and well we know what's happened last
bunch of games i think that levy should
feel good
agreed uh the only thing i don't like is
the pawn on a4 i don't think it's a big
deal but
yeah i wish that pawn was like on a2
instead
e4 played and i agree with you there's
there's h4 falling but
e5 i oh sorry i guess we take and
there's e7 that's loose
oh we should have taken the knight on d5
probably that would have but that would
have taken away
g6 bishop at five bishop takes a five
queen for check at least you
save your king and trade off some pieces
he does just that huge move
by uh by greg there very important yeah
you were
you know calling for rook to g6 the only
way i saw to stop it at least in a nice
looking way was this move here and now
levy's spending time and greg is
right back in this thing whose king is
really weaker
yeah that's what i'm saying i don't like
the move a4 in general it looks a little
bit open knight takes d5
played and you talk about tactics it
looks like black's position
is falling apart here queen each oh
about the queen he just hung the queen
and he can't believe he just laughs
about it but he just gave his queen and
levy is ice cold he's not reacting
well i think i think he's wondering what
the heck that was from his opponent
because that's the whole point of nate
d5 right that was surprising to say the
least and
greg we know he needed to right the ship
probably last game
but now is really the time with under
eight minutes remaining
and levy on a five-game winning streak
this is a critical game right here i
said something's gonna have to change
when um when we finally see
levy take the lead so now levy is
leading in the match everything greg was
doing
stalling tactics whatever you gotta do
the exact opposite you gotta play a
little bit more aggressive
and you cannot i don't think he can drop
this game no but i do like this
version better for greg than the
previous ones because his bishop was on
e3
now his bishop's on g3 making that rook
on jade
not feel particularly strong and still
the same problems structurally exist
in black's position and now with the
queen on a6 i mean
okay queen c that's the way to try to
castle queen d3 hits h7
c4 next and black's king is still in the
center
and these these openings uh for levy
i feel like they never go well when greg
is able to just trade
because i feel like what ends up
happening is this h7 pawn is just
attacked and how do you defend it
f5 well thanks i'll take that pawn too
yeah
it's pinned so he can just steal h7
right now if he wants it
he plays rook h1 he wants to take on
each other with the rook that pawn's not
going anywhere so might as well
and if you play f5 now for black there's
knight e5 so you can't get away with
that
c5 play levy is he's trying to create
something of course this move makes a
lot of sense but
you know ice cold he just plays d takes
c5 says all right your knight can move
but i don't think you have any good
discoveries and he didn't want to give
levy enough time to take back with a
piece on c5 now the pawns are separated
with that split pawn structure they're
weaker and rook d3
making sure the rook is safe trying to
bring that up into the position i think
okay queen a six check looks good i'm
trying to find some kind of
not a mating move but like can i play a4
or is that
two tunneled i i feel like this position
is
getting a little bit back in levy's
favor i'm not his favorite but he's he's
climbing back at that advantage like the
c
pawn running and i i don't really like
the coordination from greg of the last
couple of moves his king
is looking all alone c3 the rook's on
the d file queen's on the c file
i mean this is looking good for black
yeah if you played b3 just queen c5
30 queen a3 check and queen takes f2 and
it's white's king that's in danger
so the last bunch of moves have clearly
favored levy the clock
under 10 seconds for greg you got to
move he's got to move he's really
let this one slip after a great opening
and he does play b4 so
same idea but he didn't want to deal
with queen c5 right
and now queen d6 queen d3 you can offer
the queen exchange
so you have to play queen d3 you have no
other choice he does that
and if you're levy do you trade queens
here he says no
an e5 okay wow great move 91 though i
like that rerouting to get to the d3
square
rook d4 rookie for this rook aj check
i think yep where kj it's a good place
to start
um forces the okay okay
yeah i think the the the queen needed to
get involved there foreign
knight c5 and then 96 check was it a
threat okay
oh we lost in time he went on time oh my
goodness
wow we are we have uh you know folks
we've reached our cruising altitude of
full tilts for
uh greg shahadi i don't know how many
it's been six in a row robert
um it has been yes six in a row at this
point
wow just completely one-sided in the
bullet this far we still have time
four and a half minutes left if greg can
take this game
he will have time for another but he
cannot afford to lose if he loses the
match uh the game excuse me he also will
very likely lose the match this this one
is everything um i
i thought that last one was pretty much
it but
now now this one actually will be it if
he
loses this one i don't see the comeback
happening um
levy has you know he stumbled into this
uh bullet segment i feel like robert but
ever since that one loss
he's been unstoppable he looked dejected
he looked down he did not seem happy
about what was going on and yet
once the bullet started greg won the
first game it
seemed i think this might get away from
levy and yet here he is with a
two-game lead with just under four
minutes
remaining and queen d5 played watch out
for queen a2 that could be some
wow c4 okay very aggressive move i feel
like
this could get a little bit loose uh for
levitt knight g3
is the the plan after queen e3 though so
where do you move your
queen to i don't see an easy square as
rook h6 okay
that does make sense and rooks you
perfect move from levy's just playing so
well right now
gotta play h5 um next i think
uh h5 knight g3 uh rook g5
trap the queen but this queen it can be
trapped if you just go back in 94 the
queen has nowhere to go
94 queen to five rook g5 i think he sees
it do you think he notices it now
yep there it is and you see that he just
takes a big breath there you go resign
greg you you have to resign
yeah you got to design quick
and i mean he needs to win this game
like
instantly which is just just click claim
win
yeah right uh move one resigns
yep i think i think this is uh i think
this is gonna be
levy's match we're still in it but just
with the time taking in two and a half
minutes
that's as long as this game is probably
gonna last
i again i'm kind of skeptical about
black's position here with the king in
the center and pushing a pawn to e5
in this manner but perhaps this is still
in
levy's general repertoire and
okay can you shoot now he can castle and
okay black is doing well
well we we've seen that rook a3 to g3 to
g7 is in
levy's general repertoire so i think
he's okay here
yeah knight takes e5 for example just
looks real
real good yep
this is it i mean he made an insane
comeback robert he took off
something just changed within him
and the first bullet game did not go his
way and then after that
he's won six in a row and right now it's
looking like
seven he's ascended
yeah this is looking like it's gonna be
seven in a row after a loss so it's not
like
it's not like he just came into the
bullet just won every game and we're all
like wow
you know levy we knew he was a beast and
bullet but look what he just did
he actually came in and lost and it
looked really good
for greg coming out of the gate and then
to come back
from that and still get the uh the win
is super impressive
he's book ended this match he started
with two wins
then greg went four out of five and now
greg you know won the first bullet game
and was leading
down the stretch of the three-minute
portion and now levy won
six and about to be seven in a row it
seems so bishop takes f1
just the knight on f8 can't move g2 is
hanging you're already up material
and rook's d1 might be the oh the
necessary
move here and brook takes f2 and then
some mates work g7 or rook takes f2
yeah the wheels came off and greg
he gets one more game but it's a four
point lead for levy and
we say this often where the match seems
closer than the score may indicate
the four point lead for levy just 15
minutes ago we were talking about hey
maybe levy has enough time
to get back in this thing and then he
just won every single game since
yeah and then it's funny we were talking
about
having enough time to make a comeback
and now we're talking about having
enough time for greg to make it come
back and all those uh
all those times earlier he shaved time
off the clock it's like ah
maybe i actually need that right now
yeah
and well we see this is the last game 10
seconds remaining unless there's a
resignation in the next few moves
this is the final one and what is
happening here b7 couldn't be captured
because queen takes d2 is checkmate
i this seems like some sort of
not theory necessarily but known
position to both
i think it's like a just a trap i guess
like this idea of queen e2
b5 hitting the bishop on h5 is kind of a
theme i guess
feels like one learned from hikaru
because he plays b3 all the time so
uh you know levy and hikar obviously
collaborate a lot i wonder if
it's paying off here with the opening
knowledge and the amazing bullet play
well i don't think he's played d3 in the
match
today so it's funny he's bringing it
bringing it out when
uh when the match is already over this
is what we call the victory lap
as time is officially up match is
officially
over um levy is taking this one we just
wait to see what the final score line is
going to be it could also be
a message to roberto hey you might need
to prepare another opening
for our match because you expected this
handful
let's add another one to the mix and
that is a problem for
players at such a high level as you need
to prepare and they play
six different openings you don't know
which one to expect yep
that is a uh that's a good point ever
annoying when
you play players that have a quite a big
repertoire
yes and okay last game just trying to
see where we're at here
even material white with the bishop hair
black
with i don't know pawn h4
control some dark squares here that's
why i played bishop f4 to
trade off the bishops and take over the
dark squares but
we know who's making to the final from
this side of the bracket it is levy
rosman
and greg can just take one for the road
a victory here if he can get it
because i do like his position yeah
knight on f4 is super strong and even if
you trade
it off knight f2 knight d3 there's going
to be another knight going to e7
and g6 and there it is it's going to
replace it
and knight c5 that's good you're hitting
the pawn e6 but that knight and f4 is
so strong there
i think that black from a strategic
point of view is dominating this
position
as white's pieces are stuck being
passive there's bishop one f1 in
particular but i like what levy did
rookies take and see uh c5 i think you
can get some
fun stuff going that looks great and
rook a1 now you don't even need c5
because the king moved up
yep he does anyway he had his choice
is definitely turning around and yeah i
mean let's look at the time as well
and can get knight f7 check yeah it
wasn't a free rookie he might have
thought this was a free brook in the
corner of the night
g6 is covering yeah and look at 95 right
knight b4
protecting c6 because of the and id3
whoa
oh my gosh and that exchange sack
probably
not advisable but he goes for it anyway
he's gonna
i don't i don't mind it um because he's
running it's knights are so tricky
um knight f4 is coming
yeah knight takes f4 is definitely
coming and g5 to keep that knight safe
and sound
there's b5 though okay king takes d5 oh
hang c6 with check or not
just one of these bullet games yeah one
of those bullet games
hard to comment on knight d3 though
watch out knight g2 there's check
rookie six kingdom knight of four back
getting forked all over the place
yeah knights are so true oh look at that
rookie eight move
and he smiled and laughed he's like hey
i tried to get you there but you
didn't fall for it you had enough time
and well that's the match that's a
thirteen and a half ten and a half win
for levy rosman
amman what did we just see here um
well we just saw a cheeky try at the end
but not one that levy is gonna care too
much about because
we just saw one of the craziest
comebacks that i can say especially at
the semi-final and final stage we know
how tough
these competitors are and they all
deserve to be
in the semi-finals and in the finals um
by winning this match so
i mean this is just two guys playing
some very very good chess i thought the
openings were on point today
the blunders were on point as well we
made sure we got our fair share but
um greg just sort of like started out a
little shaky
came into his form in the five minute
and three minute blitz super
impressed with his uh his chest there
started the bullet and it seemed to be
like
that the recipe for a greg shahadi win
that the wheels just came off the wagon
and you know it was just a train wreck
at some point
and some of those lawsuits like that
dropping the queen on h4
that's those are head scratcher moments
we're like greg you're way
better than this and you could do better
but he lost the thread and
all credit to levy he found his footing
in the bullet and he was able to take
this match
everybody please stay where you are
we'll be back with the players in just a
few
for the post-match interviews and
welcome back everyone we are joined by
the players myself and robert are joined
by
greg shahadi and levy rosman uh we're
going to go right into it uh jump over
to you levy i mean the emotions
you must be feeling something right now
how's it feel after what was
one of the most impressive bullet
comebacks that we've seen
in the tournament so far well
uh going into this uh my literally had
one strategy and it was to keep it close
until the bullet
um because i figured i would have an
advantage there uh
i don't know if you guys remember the
second to last three plus one game
i clicked my king i was down one i click
my king i click my rook on a8 to move
rook c8 i long castle i get destroyed
so i'm like really molding at this point
and i and greg just killed me in the
next game and when i went down three i
was like okay it can't get any worse
than this
um because like i figured okay i did it
once right maybe i can do it again
and then when i went down four i
literally was like okay i mean whatever
just
play you know put pieces on squares um
and yeah i mean i it it worked out the
tactics and bullet are
are pretty crazy but uh no i mean
significantly less emotion than last
time it's been a pretty stressful week
for reasons to chat and you guys know so
i'm just happy to be in the finals yeah
and greg over
to you i mean you played some great
chess in the middle portion of this
match
but one decision that we kept asking
about was game one
you had a draw in the back you had a
repetition
and then you essentially handed levy the
point almost as if you thought he might
pre-move or something so what was going
through your mind at that point and why
did you decide to play on
you know i saw queen d2 after king h2 i
didn't see queen f3
and queen d2 i had some plan um and he
had three seconds and i had like a
minute
and i'm just like you know yeah um but
after queen of three i guess i'm losing
that was that was kind of sad oh that
was uh there was also like three like
three games in
or something i i like gave a game away
you took on b2 you went back to f6 and i
was like what the hell am i doing i've
never sworn that much in one blitz game
i mean just the game yeah you like took
the pawn went back took another pawn i
was like oh just dead lost
nice yeah yeah the uh
the match definitely seemed like it was
like a rough start for you greg
uh you made a big comeback and the the
five minute and three minute
portions seemed to go your way and then
when the bullet came around
it actually started really well for you
you had that game one
and you know as as levi was mentioning
it kind of seemed like ah this is the
greg shahadi recipe for a win uh what
happened after that the wheels just fell
off
well you know you never know how bullets
gonna feel like sometimes i feel like
i'm bad at it
but you know sometimes you just win a
few games and then i won that first game
and i'm like oh maybe i'm fine at bullet
actually and then the next game i had a
really good position on this alacrine
so i'm like i'm gonna win i'm gonna get
by five everything looks okay and then
everything
just crumbles just disaster every game
um after that you know he's really good
at bullet and i couldn't
oh that yeah that game when it was four
and it was the alakan
i i had completely given up it's almost
sometimes like you just surrender
yourself to whatever and then you win a
game you're like wait a minute and you
start like believing
and then it just i mean bullet is just
nuts because the openings are crazy it's
all nonsense
you just do whatever now greg is
ridiculously strong at openings
preparing for greg it's like
i mean it's like going to the dentist
it's like it's like i'm just gonna
i'm gonna do whatever this is this is
not his openings are like he beats like
super gm's every weekend title tuesday
so
well levy i was going to ask you that
question actually but openings you were
switching off between the caracan and
the french
how are you choosing which game to play
what are we just mixing it up because
greg is so well prepared
no so my my logic was that i was going
to play the karo khan
uh the line that he plays in the two
nights is i mean it's i actually that's
one thing
gary if i have one gripe i don't know
why you played the two nights caracon
it's just there's
uh it's so depressing for both sides but
um
no i mean i the the plan was to play
this stupid french that i play
in blitz in three one and and one one
because it's it's bad but
it's just tricky enough that but greg
even handled those positions fine it was
like way later
that things got weird and then i
prepared this idea in um
the anti i don't want to go into his
grunfeld i mean let's be serious this is
a i am not a gm there's no gruenfield
theory here so
uh just played this one idea and had fun
with it
yeah not that the openings were
definitely a big story uh
levy there was something on camera that
i certainly didn't understand what the
take a nap is this is this
now a signature of yours oh no no no
uh that was uh that was subliminal
messages like
greg like talks a lot of trash so i was
you know i was like
there was the in the i wanted to do the
nap thing when i got a knockout and then
immediately lost like three straight
[Music]
throw in some stuff for gamepl crowd
i'll wink sometimes or you know you guys
know how it goes sometimes you'll just
see a forehead so
you need to mix it up let the chat have
fun too so
but uh it comes back man you lose three
straight you almost lose the match so
for sure and well i guess levy you know
you guys played a long match let me go
in a second but what do you make of
roberto molina your opponent in the
final what do you
see as that matchup looking like in your
chances
um i think i've played roberto just like
wow i've played him
19 times uh it is
eight wins for me and 11 for him i think
so
but uh no he's really strong he's like
2800 blitz and bullet i
probably have zero advantage there i'm
just gonna have to rely on
i don't know i don't know i don't know
what i'll have to rely on just
go and do my best yeah so yeah well you
haven't had to rely on it yet so
i guess we'll all find out what that'll
be when the match takes place it'll be
sometime
very very soon i'm sure greg it's your
exit
from the uh from the tournament but i
mean you've uh
gave us hell of a match and uh all the
matches with you with you
are very exciting to call i can speak
for myself when i knew i was in trouble
in the bullet and
it was like a 3-1 game or a five-minute
game where i was like
way up on time he had like four seconds
left and he played all these tactics
like knight takes f4 you know what i'm
talking about yeah
in four seconds and then he won the game
and i'm like i'm scared
no there was a game you also in the time
scramble like defended the two rooks
versus two rooks position like knight
versus bishop and
at that point i actually was i was
scared of you so i'm glad we traded this
emotion with one another for three hours
yeah
well we'll let you two you know regain
your composure it was a great match
everyone was very excited congrats again
levi we'll see you soon and greg
sorry didn't go your way but you provide
the entertainment every single time
you're out of here
i thank you thanks for having me good
luck geez greg good luck man
you guys there you have it we have our
finals
we have levy rosman taking on roberto
molino you heard it from levy himself
they played uh 19 times 11 wins
for roberto nine uh no that's eight
before levy doing math quickly but we
also don't know what the time controls
were he just told us the results so
anything could happen that one amman
what do you make of that
final match up oh man it's been uh it's
been quite a journey you know all these
all these matches commentating with you
robert just
whittling down to the two best players
in the competition
and i think they're there for a reason
these guys deserve to be there
um levy taking down uh greg who's an
incredibly formidable opponent
definitely has earned his spot and
roberto has sort of a little more
quietly just made his way all the way to
the finals very very
impressive and i think what we're gonna
see from that match
is uh another bit of a style match-up i
think that
there are certain things that are just
gonna be part of the match for sure
we're gonna see our time pressure
from from levy and we're gonna see our
queen trades and technical approach
from roberto molina so that's gonna be a
very exciting final i
haven't even wrapped my head around um
that match to
to make a prediction but i know you'll
quiz me on it uh when we commentate that
match so i'll save it for them
i will and i'm going to make a
prediction which is not bold at all we
are going to see a heck of a lot of the
keracon
because they both play it they can agree
they've been doing it nonstop so we will
have
to see who is the better player in the
all pawns no hope opening
but amman i mean seriously another great
time with you my friend
it's just such a blast to cover this
event such
thrilling games time controls with
people down to the waning second still
pulling off amazing tactics it just was
a
great great time yeah no it's always
always a lot of fun
commentating hanging out with the chat
we hope that you guys uh enjoyed
today's show it was a lot of fun from
the booth we we like the i am not a gm
tournament because it's the the right
amount
of good chess and good blunders i think
robert
for sure we all make mistakes but when
the time starts ticking and you're down
bullet
more happened that was the case today
but levy rosman
gotham chess the deserving champion greg
shotty gave me all he could handle
but levy moves on to the final we want
to thank our producers
everybody behind the scenes making this
event possible and of course the chat
the mods thank you so much for being
here
we hope you'll tune in and i believe the
next match will be in a few days keep an
eye out i'm sure
post on twitter everywhere on social
media so you will not want to miss it
but for now
we have to say goodbye and if i'm not
mistaken there's an arena kings coming
up is that right
i believe that is uh believe that is the
case robert so we'll we'll pass the
people off uh
over there i guess well enjoy the arena
kings anyone can play but only streamers
can win and you all win when chess is
involved so
bye everybody thanks for being here and
we'll see you very soon
you